the ships crash and Splinter against The
Rock men scream as they're tossed Into
the Water by the force of it but they
don't fear drowning they fear something
far more powerful and terrifying as they
land in the water huge pitch black hands
reach up to receive them in a place
beyond darkness and impurity all things
will be revealed those in pursuit of
spiritual enlightenment are sure to find
it on the high seas of life so long as
they map out their course with precision
and sail dauntlessly towards it but
their souls must also be wary for
wherever there are oceans to explore
there be monsters it is a raining
morning on the coast of the island of
kushu a modest fishing vessel gently
crests over the waves of the Sea of
Japan carrying with it a successful Hall
back to the port of the rural settlement
it departed from a couple of hours prior
the crew are all trades people local to
the area and many many are parents and
grandparents whose children have long
since grown up and left their home
Village for the opportunities of city
life for the older generation that was
left behind the Bounty of the sea is all
they know the marine life that the Aging
Fisher folk bring in is the lifeblood of
the village economy the population
depends on the kindness of nature to
avoid falling into poverty and is
accustomed to working against the
elements when it becomes necessary
tsunamis and typhoon have threatened the
balance of this way of life before but
over several decades the villagers have
proven themselves resilient to the most
extreme fluctuations of natural forces
but even a firm backbone beaten into
shape by hard work and suffering will
buckle and bend in the churning melstrom
of alien Tides a black do shape in the
valley between passing wakes Heralds the
arrival of a fearsome giant with no
further indication of its intentions the
Great dark thing emerges from the depths
the Fisher folk steady their vessel as a
gargantuan Ripple disrupts the surface
of the water giving way to a humanoid
figure that was a full 5 m in length
when the fishing boat had left the
harbor the weather POS no obstacle save
for a veil of fog but now in the face of
this unfathomable being the pelting
rainwater swirled around the sturdy
rubber boots of the crew as if the ocean
below was beckoning them to surrender to
the Darkness an icy blade of fear
pierced the heart of Mr Nakamura the man
who now commanded the wheel of the ship
his efforts to make sense of the
horrible sight in front of him brought
him back to a moment from his distant
childhood his parents had taken him to
visit a Buddhist temple in the
countryside and when he recklessly
wandered off young Nakamura wound up
lost in the dark corridors beneath the
grounds to a child his age it seemed as
though he was trapped in an inescapable
Labyrinth the only thing the boy could
muster the strength to do was head
towards the faint glow of torch light he
soon Came Upon a statue of the amitaba
Buddha sitting peacefully between the
contained flames of the Torches Nakamura
relished the temporary piece of the
moment but his composure did not remain
intact for long a hand from the dark
grabbed his wrist and at that moment he
looked up to see the bald head of one of
the temple monks the orange robed Man's
eyes were fixed downward at the boy and
contained a mixture of contempt and
relief that Nakamura had never seen
before you are found over 70 years later
Mr Nakamura could see nothing in the
terrible giant that had besieged his
boat so clearly as he saw the silhouette
of a Buddhist monk but even with the
ominous recollection of that formative
memory coursing through the Old
Fisherman's body like an electrical
current it was obvious that the monster
was human only only in shape the Flesh
of the thing was the color of octopus
ink and its eyes its bulous and
disquieting eyes were big even in
proportion to the Giant's colossal head
worse despite their almost cartoonish
absurdity the eyes of the things seemed
to hold within them that same barely
defined look of bewildered judgment it
was too much for Mr Nakamura to take and
when his heart gave out his hands thre
the ship wheel in a jerking Arc that
brushed it straight against the waves
most of the other Fisher folk were too
stunned by the giant to properly get
their bearings and multiple members of
the crew Nakamura included tumbled
overboard into the waves those who
remained on Deck could see that the
wheel was drifting aimlessly or rather
would have if their focus was not still
drawn to the black monk that had Arisen
just moments ago the giant raised a
massive dark hand above the waters and
arranged its fingers in such a way as to
mimic the Vitara hand gesture seen in
many Buddhist statues as if on Q a
Consortium of black rubbery tentacles
broke the surface of the ocean and faned
out towards the boat like so many
grasping hands one of these pseudopods
wrapped itself around the barely
conscious body of Mr Nakamura plucking
him from under the water and raising him
into the Misty Sea Air in response to
the tentacles the other Fisher folk
panicked and scrambled back onto the
boat with those aboard extending Nets
and ores to assist their fellow crew two
terrifying minutes passed before the
adherent black thing vanished into the
Mist along with Mr Nakamura his longtime
peers and co-workers panted and
sputtered trying to make any kind of
sense of what just happened when they
made their way home to the Village Port
the only question that seemed to matter
was which of them would have to place
the upsetting call to nakamura's
daughters in Tokyo who could bear to
deliver the news to her that her
steadfast father had been taken by a
giant of the sea while thankfully rare
incidents such as the sudden nautical
Abduction of Mr Nakamura are not
unexplained or even isolated to cases in
the Sea of Japan since as early as the
12th century sightings of aquatic Titans
resembling night black monks have been
recorded by a precursor to the SCP
Foundation known as the Bureau of onmo
back then these creatures were referred
to as umib Boo or sea bonds bonds being
a Chinese and Japanese term for Buddhist
monk in the current day the Yumi bosu
have been reclassified as SCP
2781 and because of the predatory way
that the Giants hunt their targets and
their extreme resistance to containment
they have been designated ker class as
of right now there are thought to be
upwards of 900 instances of SCP 2781 in
existence while SCP 2781 entities could
potentially appear anywhere in the Epic
lay of the planet's oceans they have
historically tended towards inhabiting
the waters around countries where there
have been a pervasive and widespread
practice of the Buddhist Faith an
archived file recovered from the Bureau
of Ono reveals that a group of East
Asian Pirates or Wako ran a foul of one
of the creatures while searching for
treasure in a Seaside Cave the seafaring
Cutthroats had previously fired on a
trading ship from Korea and driven it
against the rocks of a remote Japanese
island many of the goods on board had
been carried in by the tides and
required strong swimmers to access but
during the hunt for spoils the Wako were
interrupted by the malevolent presence
of an entity that manifested itself
within the coastal crass the yiu or SCP
2781 could not stretch to its full
height within the cavern and thus glared
down at the pirates with an acute angle
to its posture the Pirates were
completely defenseless having left
behind their metal weapons and guns on
the ship out of concern for rust and
ruined powder while none of these
criminal Sea Dogs were religious their
plunder had brought enough gold Buddha
statues to recognize the familiar
gestures of SCP
2781 then according to the report a
strange phenomenon occurred within the
cavern the Pirates gasped in sheer
disbelief as the stone walls were bathed
in light and the creature began to raise
its head the ceiling was suddenly more
pliable as if it had changed into a
softer material before they knew it the
Wako found themselves in a wondrous Cave
of pure gold The Entity then tore chunks
of the gold away from the wall crushing
the metal with its bare hands like a
chef might Crush spice a small fortune
of coins dropped from between the umumi
bosu's fingers though the tempting
promise of wealth called to the men not
one of them could find the courage to
attempt to seize it this was because of
the entity's unblinking Gaze which felt
so profoundly wrong that even being
within sight of it felt like drowning
the walk were already swimming away as
fast as they could when the giant
Unleashed its tentacles to swallow its
chosen Target and disappear into the
ether later in the tavern of a nearby
port a researcher for the Bureau of Ono
obtained a detailed version of the
encounter before administering
rudimentary herbal amnestics to the
Pirates through their pitcher of sake
which all of them were partaking in to
dull the insanity of what the more
superstitious among them were calling
Divine punishment while the full scope
of SCP P 2781 reality warping abilities
is still being studied displays such as
the transmutation of the cavern into
gold in the case of the wo have been
noted in several other sightings it
seems as though the entities are able to
perform religious miracles in other
words exert Godlike authority over all
forces mineral and Elemental the use of
this ability seems to be an uncommon
occurrence even within targeted attacks
seeming to reflect an understanding on
the umumi Bozo's part not to want to
abuse Lo its miraculous power of all the
sightings ever documented no entity that
is part of SCP 2781 has ever attempted
to transmute a living human or animal
the Bureau of Ono also suggests that the
overall number of Umi Bozo in the sea
experienced a mysterious increase during
the reign of toyotomi hidoshi and that
the startling frequency of their
appearance may have influenced Japan's
inability to claim victory in the imagin
war there were so many disperate reports
of the entities that a few you even
reach the great UniFi ear since even the
bureau didn't have the authority to give
amnestics to the chancellor of the realm
the knowledge of SCP 2781 lurking in the
ocean was likely an additional factor in
hideyoshi's well documented mental
decline the SCP Foundation data has
picked up where the Bureau of on Mayo
left off centuries ago and had begun to
chart the alarming number of targeted
hunts that instances of SCP 2781 have
committed over the years sometimes the
culprit is is not immediately provable
as an instance but a closer look at the
circumstances reveals its presence for
example there was the case of Max Powell
a 15-year-old American Teenager who was
thought to have been kidnapped while his
family was aboard a commercial sea liner
traveling to Hong Kong on the day of his
disappearance Max was enjoying a swim in
one of the cruise ship's on Deck pools
witness testimony says he was just
present one moment and simply gone the
next Max's parents and the Lifeguard on
duty had no idea a how to process the
situation and though both parties were
sure that Max had never left their sight
the grief of it all got the better of
them and a heated argument began
security footage from one of the ship's
cameras reveals a portion of the truth
and thus the foundation seized it and
used amnestics to make sure the events
were not public knowledge there is a
brief moment right before Max Powell
disappears from view where a thin
wirelike strand of black seemed to snake
across the deck and into the swimming
pool another camera feed from the same
day reveals The Telltale outline of an
SCP 2781 entity was visible keeping Pace
with the ship along its Hall it seems as
though the entity had manifested in an
attempt to seize a new human being as a
Target but found none submerged in the
ocean and therefore had to shift its
focus to one of the passengers in the
swimming pool which sadly appeared to be
Max Powell this incident confirmed a
widely theorized belief about SCP 278 1
the fact that it is only able or at
least willing to abduct targets who are
partially submerged in water while boats
are often involved in most of SCP 2781
manifestations on record this is likely
a side effect of the fact that such
vessels tend to carry many humans at
once and thus increase the chances that
one of them will wind up being a Target
in other words there is nothing stopping
a SCP 2781 entity from choosing someone
who is simply in the vicinity as a
Target provided they meet the
requirement of being submerged following
the 2020 Olympic Games in Tokyo an
Simone Bergman a member of the German
swim team decided to stain the country
for a bit of additional training she was
fresh off of winning a gold medal in the
100 meter backstroke the first in her
career and according to her own
statements wanted to make as many
memories as she could before she
returned to Germany but she never would
actually be able to return and Simone
Bergman went missing in the Canon St
and her body was never recovered the
cause of her disappearance was uncertain
until recently but in light of new
evidence It is believed that her fate
was at the hands of an SCP 2781 entity
further data suggests that The Uncanny
resemblance between SCP 2781 entities
and gigantic human monks goes deeper
than a mere aesthetic coincidence this
is corroborated by the existence of SCP
2781 daa a pure land that exists beyond
the known boundaries of space and time
it is theorized that this remote
Dimension is where the entities of SCP
2781 dispense the targets of their
attacks following the moment when they
vanish from existence there are no other
known ways to enter SCP 2781 daa other
than being ushered in by an instance of
SCP 2781 but it has been discovered that
there are two ways to leave the pure
land the first is to transcend mortal
existence in order to become a Buddha
and the second is to return to the the
physical world as a bista understood in
this context to be a manifested instance
of SCP 2781 in Buddhism the purpose of
the bista is to spare itself the
completion of its own spiritual journey
in order to guide the rest of humanity
toward Enlightenment thus SCP 2781 daa
is an extension of that purpose and
confers the benefits of the claro
cognizant awareness upon its occupants
while it is impossible to know the
ultimate truth of what befalls the
targets who chose to reach nirvana we
learn much of what we know now through
engaging in Sign Language communication
with a voluntarily albeit temporarily
contained instance of SCP 2781 that has
self-identified itself as Nakamura this
unusually docile instance of an SCP 2781
bav Vista described the pure land as a
contemplative place and alleged that it
even had a chance meeting with Olympic
gold medalist and Simone Bergman during
its time in that world Nakamura
indicated to the foundation members that
it wished to return to its Village and
release others from their own
attachments and labors but at the same
time requested that the foundation
contact a woman it identified as its
daughter this the SCP 2781 instance
indicated was its own attachment that
needed to be shed in order for it to let
go of its Earthly obligations we
informed the instance that amnestics had
already been administered to both Mr
nakamura's daughter as well as all the
Fisher folk that had been on board the
vessel the day that Nakamura was
targeted as a response to this
information The Entity demonstrated that
it was no longer willing to cooperate
with Foundation staff it brandished its
tentacles and was able to insens snare a
member of mobile task force Zeta 66
before Vanishing in the expected manner
further observation will need to be
conducted to determine how much of a
target's former identity factors into
how it is changed as a result of
entering SCP 2781 daa but we will be
closely monitoring 34-year-old minako
Nakamura as well as other known members
of the Nakamura family in the meantime
just in case they end up following in
the footsteps of dear old dad violent
chaos unfolds across the shoreline huge
fleshy tendrils Slither out of the water
grabbing people who try to flee and drag
them into the depths as giant harpoons
made of bone whiz across the beach
cutting down unfortunate sunbathers and
droves it is a terrifying Massacre but
you'd never in a million million years
be able to guess its source on April
10th 2010 something strange began to
happen in the three Portlands now the
anomalous extradimensional city state
that overlaps with the locations of
Portland Oregon Portland Maine and the
aisle of Portland is no stranger to
unusual occurrences so it took the
population a little while to notice that
something was happening but for some
unknown reason sailboats and motorboats
were beginning to vanish from the City
the disappearances occurred overnight
when there was no one around to witness
them but slowly the citizens began to
notice that their friends and family
members were going out in their
watercrafts and never returning home by
April 15th the civilians were becoming
noticeably concerned fearing the worst
on April 16th their worst fears were
confirmed when two local ghosts onar
Ahmed and Greg Moore went for a
nighttime stroll along the harbor they
heard a sudden commotion and rushed to
the scene of the disturbance they
arrived just in time to see a living
individual being dragged into the watery
depths by a large veinlike tendril ammed
asked Greg to wait on land while he
ventured out into the water to look for
the victim unfortunately Ahmed never
came back and Greg took his story to the
three Portland's Police Department after
waiting a few days for the local maned
and clam populace to migrate the FBI
unusual incidence unit mounted a formal
in investigation on the morning of April
17th all of the missing Vehicles
suddenly reappeared this left the uiu
and the people of the city with even
more questions where had all the boats
gone why were they suddenly back and
what had happened to the missing people
who had not been returned along with
them on April 19th uiu agents dove into
the harbor to search for any unusual
activity and while they didn't spot
anything especially strange they did
discover that there were fewer animals
in the harbor than usual usual on April
21st the threat that had been praying on
the citizens of three Portlands actually
made itself known at 1119 a.m. 17 boats
moved away from the docks on their own
drifting up onto Shore though no one
could be seen captaining any of them as
the boats lined up they began to form a
wall blocking access to the water no one
could get in or out civilians watched in
shock as the boats began to warp and
change before their eyes
growing thick masses of scales on their
surfaces sprouting Harpoon guns that
fired bony projectiles and slashing
veiny tendrils at anyone within reach
the citizens began to panic running in
every direction in an attempt to escape
the Monstrous boats but they were too
slow to evade the attacks and the boats
snatched them off of the shore and
yanked them aboard using their harpoons
to impale those who managed to run
farther than the tendrils could stretch
as the army of Flesh boats closed in
around the shore a tugboat broke through
the surface of the water unlike the rest
of the boats it had a noticeable hole in
its Hull and was missing its wheelhouse
at an unnaturally quick Pace the tugboat
began to advance onto land using its
tendrils to drag itself along the shore
and into the more populous part of town
it grabbed civilians at random absorbing
their blood into its metallic surface as
it went suddenly it spotted Albert ISAT
a noted member of the Church of the
broken God and began to focus its attack
on him but before the tugboat monster
could reach ISAT a city security Golem
interfered sadly though the Golem put up
a valiant fight the anomaly was able to
destroy it by Falling onto it again and
again until the Golem was no longer able
to get back up there are few creatures
that would survive having a boat drop
itself on top of them repeatedly and
sadly the security Golem was not one of
them with the the golum out of the way
the boat continued to drag itself
through the streets wildly crashing
through the side of a local restaurant
where its owner an entity known as the
GRL was in the middle of a busy brunch
service at the sight of the invading
watercraft the grul set down his picture
of bottomless mimosas wiped his hands on
his apron and grabbed his trusty dual
wield swords from underneath the counter
he kept them there in case someone
attempted to dine and dash but he
figured they would do just fine against
a blood drinking Tugboat while the GRL
kept the tugboat busy uiu forces were
able to break through the barricade of
boats for a brief period of time
allowing more security Golems to enter
the area as well as allowing more
citizens to escape unfortunately this
little victory was short-lived as
further unforeseen Horrors drudged
themselves up from the deep the
reanimated corpses of various species
native to the harbor began to crawl out
of the water surrounding the GRL and
allowing the tugboat to escape the fight
as it made its way back to the harbor
every boat it passed attempted to toss
bodies onto the tugboat covering it in
fresh blood slowly but surely the damage
to the tugboat began to repair itself
once the boat had regained its strength
it set its sights on a previously
untouched cargo ship an observing uiu
officer determined that the boat was
somehow attempting to convert the cargo
ship to transform it into another one of
its fleshy allies but before the trans
formation could take place a cargo crate
broke open spilling over 1,000 hard tack
crackers suddenly the tugboat stopped
everything that it was doing it took one
tendril and began to count each
individual cracker that had Spilled Out
well the tugboat was distracted with its
task a citizen offered the uiu use of
their rare Metals Cannonball collection
in the fight to apprehend the aggressive
boat one particular Cannonball made from
electrum was able to puncture the hole
of one of the infected ships rendering
it motionless they were elated to have
found a weapon that worked against these
boats while the tugbo continued to count
the remaining towns people gathered all
of the electrum they could find and
began to fight back against the boats
One By One The Boat sank and all the
while the tugboat continued to count in
the meantime uiu officers managed to
free the GRL from a zombie attackers
they presented him with an electrum
Cannonball which he proceeded to punch
finger holes into and wheeled like a
bowling ball then the GRL had a score to
settle no one whether human ghost or
tugboat was going to mess with his
brunch the guru barreled towards the
harbor grabbed hold of the still
distracted Tugboat and punched it hard
with his Cannonball fist if the tugboat
could breathe the punch would have
knocked the air out of its lungs the GRL
then threw the tugboat out of the water
and continue the Savage beating before
preparing to destroy the battered
vehicle once and for all all he lifted
it up into the air jumped up to follow
it and hit it with so much force that
the tugboat caremed through the air
colliding with a portal that had
transported it to the aisle of Portland
luckily this portal could only be
unlocked via a high-speed impact from a
water-based vehicle speaking of luck an
SCP Foundation team was returning to the
aisle from a failed Mission just as the
anomalous boat appeared in their reality
the object was knocked unconscious by
the impact of its travel and the beeding
from the GRL and in its incapacitated
state it was transported to a nearby
Foundation site there it was contained
and given the designation of SCP
6426 due to its anomalous traits
including the consumption of blood a
talent for hypnosis and a compulsive
counting habit it was also given the
nickname The Vampire boat SCP 6426 is a
ker class Sapient hostile entity that in
an inactive State Bears the appearance
of a harbor Tugboat in a const an state
of rust and degradation any blood or
organs containing blood that come into
contact with the boat will be absorbed
through the metal causing the
degradation to visibly improve as a
result the most effective blood appears
to come from humans sitations and a few
specific species of
salti the entity does not only use the
absorb blood to improve its appearance
but is also capable of using it to
create organic additions to its body
including the vein-like tendrils spotted
in the three Portlands Cognito hazardous
eyes attached to bending eye stocks
Harpoon guns and cannons capable of
firing ammunition made from anomalous
species of barnacles these Barnacles are
capable of reanimating dead tissue on
contact and SCP 6426 frequently uses
them to create instances of SCP
6426 C masses of reanimated tissue that
the boat uses to Aid in its attacks or
self-defense SCP 6426 uses its tendrils
to grab prey and drag them towards
itself but the tendrils serve an
additional purpose as well each of the
tendrils has a mouth on the tip similar
in structure to that of the North
American medicinal leech when the
tendril has made contact with its prey
the mouth will then bite into the spinal
column of the creature causing its brain
function to cease as its canines grow
long and Hollow hard scales form on
their skin and their muscle mass and
bone density increase once they have
been transformed in this way organisms
taken by SCP 6426 are designated SCP
6426 these instances are used to the
entity's advantage helping it to extract
blood from victims at a distance as well
as providing an additional line of
defense and offense in the event that
SCP 6426 encounters another watercraft
it is able to use SCP 6426 daa to
convert the vehicle into an instance of
SCP 6426 DB these converted boats are
similar to SCP 6426 and are able to
function on their own however they are
unable to produce their own I stocks or
cannons unable to create SCP
6426 instances and do not appear to be
as intelligent as their creator in the
early days of its containment the exact
nature of the anomaly's intelligence was
the subject of debate amongst the
research staff however on one specific
occasion the foundation was able to
establish a line of direct Comm
communication with SCP
6426 and conduct the first and so far
the only interview with the vampiric
tugboat the inciting incident occurred
when the arrival of the foundation's
latest hard tax shipment was delayed
leaving the boat with nothing to count
and nothing to keep it occupied freed
from the bounds of counting it managed
to escape and grab hold of several
Foundation staff members with its
tendrils after Chasing the boat through
the site guards were able to Corner it
prompting the boat to absorb the bodies
it had taken and used the organic
material to produce a siren that emitted
the sound of a human voice it is through
this siren that SCP 6426 responded to
interview questions using the voice of
one of its victims Junior researcher sad
Williamson in spite of his protests was
selected to conduct the interview his
fellow staff members refused to take no
for an answer and as the newest hire the
unpleasant job fell on his shoulders
much to everyone's surprise the nly
began the conversation rather politely
saying I am so sorry I thought you were
those self-righteous lunatics from the
church I apologize profusely for any
trouble I may have caused and I want to
point out I fully support your mission
yes our first line of defense against
the undersea Menace I am more than
willing to punch sharks salans yes
right how rude of me yes Dr Williamson's
first question concerned SCP 6426
apparent intended victim back in three
Portlands Albert ISAT SCP 6426 responded
Albert his first name is really
Albert well what other relationship is
there to say besides the Hunter and the
hunted Admiral ISAT is a ruthless Man
known for terrorizing and slaughtering
people like me he was leading a search
party of those barbaric naop files
intending to gut me like a seal what do
you mean people like you Dr Williamson
inquired freethinkers of course people
who are unafraid to break from the mold
to carve their own path in life instead
of following the predetermined route set
by that ignorant check valve the church
is built upon a foundation of lies no
one's really a petty officer on this
ship we're all just cabin boys stumbling
around in the dark as we follow the
commands of an offhand
coob
if you want real power real Freedom all
you have to do is listen for the call of
the Beast open the port hole and he'll
squeeze you right
through Dr Williamson feeling rather in
over his head attempted to convince one
of his colleagues to take over when he
refused however Dr Williamson continued
um could you explicate your activity
within the harbor and how you arrived
there well after I got the B swans off
my trail I found a cave to hide in I was
forced to hide in yes forced to hide
deep in the cave which turned out to be
a tunnel surprisingly the tunnel led to
some Coastal Community where I took
Refuge licking my wounds in the safety
of the depths as those Zealot stocked
the surface I spent my time preparing
Gathering the strength necessary to face
them once more until I was ambushed
assaulted within my Hideout by a b swine
I fought for my life as I was forced out
into the open and descended upon by a
manner of monsters and freaks of this
orchestrated by that scumbag eard I was
beaten within an inch of my life before
I'm not quite sure what happened after
that I believe I was knocked unconscious
you'll have to Illuminate Me on how I
came to be in your custody at this point
the interview began to Veer in an odd
Direction
the boat expressed confusion about the
nature of Williamson's questions
specifically how little they related to
the subject of sharks and punching them
it was at this point that the site
director sought guidance from the multi
U Department a researcher there informed
Williamson about the confusion SCP 6426
had mistaken the SCP Foundation for
another organization the shark punching
Center Dr Williamson resumed the
interview prepared to play along and
keep the boat comfortable unfortunately
Le Williamson was a terrible liar yes we
are the shark punching Center we will
determine if you are a suitable
candidate to carry out the mission to
search punch and contain sh I mean
cations this verbal misstep caused SCP
6426 to become suspicious after a moment
it pieced together the truth and began
to throw itself against the wall in a
desperate attempt to escape it was
apprehended by security guards who
impaled it with a naval RAM and returned
the watercraft to its containment cell
the exact reason for its apparent fear
and hatred of the foundation is
currently unknown and the boat has made
no attempt to speak since currently SCP
6426 is kept in a 39 m x 39 MX 50 m
containment chamber beneath the chamber
there is an artificial lava tube the
tugboat has a naval Ram through its Hull
and engine holding it in place this Ram
is checked daily for signs of
degradation as it is the primary force
keeping the anomaly immobile if the ram
is ever never removed or damaged somehow
a fail safe system will activate
releasing 100 hard attack crackers and
two pieces of electrum into the
containment chamber this is intended to
keep the tugboat occupied until the
naval Rod can be replaced if for some
reason the naval Rod fails and the boat
runs out of heart attack to count well
there will be nowhere on water or land
that we can hide the diver screams A
Silent Scream as the giant Squid's beak
digs into his skin it's many grasping
tentacles grabbing him and holding him
in place nearby his fellow divers are
driven half mad with Terror as they see
mysterious figures floating towards them
through the MC and strange Russian
voices speaking in their heads nobody
can help them they're down too deep too
consumed by the darkness and the
pressure of the sea they're now at the
mercy of whatever is inside the
submarine beginning in the 1940s with
the dawn of nuclear weapons the American
government conducting the world's first
atomic weapons test and the Soviet Union
responding in kind with nuclear testing
of their own the two Powers entered an
arms race fueled by rivalry and a thirst
to prove their strength on the world
stage What followed were Decades of
Staggering technological advancements as
each Nation tried to outdo and
intimidate the other the Soviet Union
crossed into the cold reaches of outer
space deploying the satellite Sputnik
the United stat States responded with
the founding of NASA tensions reached a
fever pitch during the Cuban Missile
Crisis of 1962 as United States citizens
feared they were teetering on the brink
of nuclear war in July of 1968 the
Soviet Union the United Kingdom and the
United States came together to sign the
treaty on the nonproliferation of
nuclear weapons agreeing to abandon
their pursuit of increasing nuclear
power and turn their focus to
disarmament but several months before
before the treaty was signed the Soviet
government was dealing in Weaponry far
more dangerous than nuclear missiles
something the other world powers knew
nothing about these deadly secrets were
hidden aboard a submarine known as SCP
741 SCP 741 is the underwater wreckage
of a Soviet submarine that sank in March
of 1968 and came into the custody of the
SCP Foundation in 1999 the submarine a
version of the Charlie 2 class was
deployed under unusual circumstances
which attracted the attention of the
United States government in an attempt
to learn more about the submarine the US
government launched project redacted
which attempted to recover the vessel
from the ocean in the early 1970s they
managed to recover a few pieces of the
vessel though the specifics are highly
classified in the late 1990s the US
government contacted the SCP Foundation
informing them of a possible uclid or
ker class anomaly in Iraq at this point
it passed into the custody and
surveillance of the foundation the
submarine is on the ocean floor broken
into three pieces the hole was broken
into bits during project redacted
recovery attempt but was largely intact
when it first sank except for two holes
one just in front of the sail and one
just below the starboard missile tubes
apparently the vessel sank rapidly due
to flooding after an enemy missile
strike which occurred while it was
surfacing though all parts of the
submarine are accounted for no members
of the crew have been located
additionally none of the emergency
escape equipment on board has been used
raising further questions about what
became of the crew wherever they went
they seem to have left something behind
whenever divers are sent down to
investigate the wreckage they report
experiencing anomalous currents and
strange sea life and hearing moans
disembodied voices an incoherent
Whispering they also report seeing
blurry faintly glowing figures
Additionally the ocean life in the area
is unnaturally aggressive particularly
large squid and sharks this effect was
first noted during a manned Expedition
into the waters around the wreckage
described in incident report 1741 daa
divers a26 through a30 embarked from the
Icebreaker yamal into the waters below
with the intention of studying the
potential anomalous activity surrounding
the wreckage as the group of divers
approached the submarine they could feel
the shift in the water around them the
oppressive feeling of abnormally
increasing pressure bearing down and
threatening to crush them if their
specialized diving equipment were to
fail they knew that that would be it and
the command would have to come and fish
their corpses out of the water or even
worse they would vanish entirely meeting
the same mysterious fate as the crew of
that doomed submarine but they couldn't
fix it on that they had a job to do at
first glance the wreckage appeared
undisturbed unchanged since the previous
inspection still they needed to take a
closer look to be sure as the team got
closer to the vessel a30 was startled by
the sight of movement from within the
wreckage spotting motion through one of
the holes in the structure as something
passed by he pointed it out to his
colleagues but they dismissed it as
likely a giant isopod or spider crab
which were crawling all over the
surrounding area a30 laughed off his
jumpiness agreed that they were probably
right and continued the exploration as
planned control authorized the divers to
proceeded to the next step and a29
activated sonar and lights moving toward
the starboard side breach there a faint
glowing caught his eye the glow
resembled that of radioactive material
but when the team checked the radiation
levels in the area they remained stable
whatever the source of the glow was it
wasn't radioactive at this point his
Neutron counter began to register
something and all of a sudden a
disembodied voice could be heard saying
vili K me can you hear me the voice was
muffled and though it could be heard
over their communication channels it
emanated from somewhere in the wreckage
deep deep underwater as a29 watched a
glowing shape emerg from the darkness it
was only an outline the suggestion of a
silhouette but the shape was undeniably
familiar it looked like a person the
other divers quickly noted The
Apparition too and began to panic some
checked their nitrogen levels leing it
to be some sort of nitrogen Narcosis
While others pointed out that they
couldn't all be suffering from nitrogen
Narcosis at the same time the unknown
voice continued speaking saying help me
it is getting hard to breathe the divers
debated what to do next questioning
whether what they were seeing was even
real when all at once the humanoid
figure vanished from sight the divers
attempted to shake off the startling
encounter and they resumed their duties
the investigation proceeding as normal
after a few moments of of uneventful
work another Interruption presented
itself in the form of a 5 m long squid
swimming around the wreckage its
presence startled the divers at first
particularly those closest to the animal
but the others encouraged them to ignore
it citing the fact that there are no
records of these squid attacking humans
so they did continuing their work as the
squid circled them with apparent
curiosity a27 spotted an unusual shell
below the wreckage notably large and
difficult to identify and control
requested that they bring it up to the
surface for further inspection by a
marine biologist the diver began
attaching Hall cables to the Shell as
the squid crept closer and closer all of
a sudden a26 screamed and there was a
sudden Bloom of blood in the water the
squid despite it being uncharacteristic
behavior for its species attacked the
diver biting him savagely prompted by
cries for help from the diving team
control began to reel a26 back towards
the surface proceeding slowly to to give
him decompression time and the squid
took advantage of the slow Retreat it
chased after the diver grabbing hold of
him and biting down again tearing away
at him as it gripped him in its
tentacles still control continued
reeling him in hoping to free him from
the Squid's grasp as they yanked him to
the surface the other divers were
ordered to get themselves out of there
as fast as possible an order they gladly
obeyed as they swam back to the surface
a30 saw something else moving in the
depths he couldn't make out what it was
but the sight of it gave him a sick
feeling of dread deep in the pit of his
stomach the four divers were recovered
alive along with the shell examination
of the shell indicated that it resembled
that of the extinct orthoconic
nautiloids but it was not fossilized it
was taken for further study given the
possible implication of extinct species
anomalously manifesting in the vicinity
of SCP 714 diver 826 lost a limb and was
exposed to an unknown Venom via bites
from the attack ing squid his camera was
destroyed in the process as squid are
not known to attack humans unprovoked
this Behavior has been attributed to the
influence of SCP 741 though the exact
link between the two is yet to be
determined an anomalous pressure
gradient surrounds the wreck with a
radius of approximately 250 M starting
around the center of the submarine the
pressure in this area is much greater
than it should be given the depth of the
waters there this unusually high
pressure makes sonar analysis A
extremely difficult as well as
threatening the safety of any divers in
the vicinity of the rack the few records
that the foundation has managed to
obtain from the Russian and US
governments indicate that the submarine
was being used to transport some sort of
secret cargo though the specifics of
this cargo are still unknown there is
reason to believe that it differed from
any type of nuclear or chemical Weaponry
on a date redacted from official files
the scps basti was patrolling the area
around SCP 741 when it sonar detected
some unknown entity approaching SCP 741
from the south at a pace of 46 knots the
crew compared the acoustic signature of
the contact with known submarines and
Torpedoes but could not find a match the
basti attempted to reached the contact
via sonab buoi drops and active sonar
pings but it did not respond when the
contact crossed into the total
underwater exclusion Zone it became
classified as hostile at that point the
sonar recorded sounds of an underseen
missile launch and basti responded with
the utmost urgency the ship broke away
from its original area and fired a type
53 torpedo at the underwater threat 15
seconds after the bisti launched its
torpedo missiles of an unidentified
configuration were seen breaking the
water flying at a height of 1.8 m and a
velocity of 92 Mach the missiles did not
emit any detectable radar nor did they
respond to any launch chaff or flares
from the basti both of the missiles were
engaged by basist 3K N5 Kinsel surfac to
aair missiles and castan point defense
systems and were destroyed at 18800 M
and 210 M from Impact respectively after
the missiles were neutralized the
Hostile vessel could be heard engaging
in evasive maneuvers at this point there
were four closely spaced explosions and
the sound of a submarine disintegrating
the identity of the attacker as well as
its intention toward SCP 741 have not
yet been determined the incident
resulted in the foundation research team
suggesting an expansion of the acoustic
sensor net as well as additional Patrol
and defense assets placed in the area
additionally they advised an acquisition
of undersea retaliatory capability the
incident was classified incident 1741 DC
the sonar recordings from the scps bisti
during incident 1741 DC were taken for
further analysis by the research team
the in-depth review revealed anomalous
acoustic signatures that did not match
up with any known known forms of
propulsion including Magneto
hydrodynamic Drive currently the nature
of the unidentified attacker remains a
mystery and it has not been attributed
to any particular government or
organization following the incident
involving the scps bisti an American
intelligence agent reached out to the
foundation offering further insight into
the secretive government programs
looking into as SCP 741 he agreed to sit
for an interview with a foundation
researcher assigned to the project on
the condition that his identity remained
protected the SCP researcher's name is
absent from the official file as well
the two men sat in a foundation
interview room and the interviewer asked
his informant why he chose to come
forward given the US government had
simply chosen to sit on this information
for 30 years you've seen those reports
project redacted now we know that part
too how the directors didn't make the
connection is beyond me that and the
stuff the redacted pulled up yeah the
other part you don't hear about is what
some of the research team Di of and the
crew Men We buried Just Uniforms also
the nuclear device we recovered wasn't a
missile or torpedo Warhead it was a
demolition charge does that make any
sense after all those Clues I had to
come forward why the director and didn't
is something I can't fully explain this
particular statement puzzled the
foundation researcher raising questions
he hadn't anticipated only uniforms did
this mean that the sub had been unmanned
the informant replied no no no not
unmanned there were no bodies but
personal effects were everywhere along
with uniforms there was some blood human
before you ask on one of the Torpedoes
in a bit of skin where somebody probably
crushed his hand load in the thing just
no bodies left when I first looked into
all this I had no clue what the hell had
gone on down there but I started putting
things together the foundation agent
began to speculate based on the mounting
evidence could it have been a Soviet
weapons program a deadly biological
agent some kind no no it wasn't that I
thought maybe it could have been so I
dialed up some of my contacts at bio
preparent as spies wind up owing each
other favors after a while and they
denied it vly not your usual cover up
Boney either they clearly stated that
whatever the sub was carrying it wasn't
theirs they wanted know part of it sound
like he was going to puke when I
mentioned redacted doctor do you have
any idea what it takes to make a
bioweapons researcher sick now that
wasn't what really bugged me though what
really kept me awake at night was the
KGB file that fell into our hands they
mentioned a covert op by the Soviet
military against an internal unnamed
faction to get rid of a quote terrifying
weapons that even the Soviet Union can't
safely control they wanted to lose it
whatever it was or maybe fob it off onto
the US of course that all came to light
right before the Iron Curtain fell and
given the atmosphere at the time it was
practically impossible to convince the
directors said they weren't talking
about nukes and even once I did they
still didn't even think this was worthy
of action I mean the redacted would
probably have me hang for treason if
they ever find me but it was worth the
risk and by what I can gather sounds
like Russia thinks so too lone and you
have the Pacific Fleet and all the
interview continued after this point but
the rest of the conversation was
considered irrelevant and stricken from
the official file the interview left the
foundation with more questions than
answers though they were more certain
than ever that CP 741 must be kept under
strict containment procedures due to the
object's location at the bottom of the
sea as well as the unusually elevated
pressure around it it is unlikely that
many civilians will come into contact
with it however as an extra protective
measure sonar and submersible monitoring
is conducted on a periodic basis in
order to verify that the wreckage has
not been interfered with in any way the
foundation contracted Russian warships
scps bisti and Kar has been selected for
this purpose if any unauthorized
activity occurs in the area surrounding
SCP 741 nuclear and conventional
missiles may be deployed any movement of
SCP 741 is grounds for an immediate
Nuclear Strike whatever Secrets SCP 741
holds whatever it was transporting that
was even more of an uncontrollable
threat than nuclear warfare they're
better left alone down there at the
bottom of the sea the ocean is a
terrifying Place we've all heard this
statistics more than 80% of the ocean
remains unexplored that's most of the
water covering the globe completely
unmapped and unobserved by science it's
a scary thought to dwell on realizing
that there's more water than land on
Earth and the sheer expanse of that
water is so large that we've been unable
to fully explore all of it just think
there are places in the ocean that have
never been seen by a human who knows
what's down there if there was ever a
personification of fear of the unknown
the ocean could definitely be it ancient
shipwrecks sunk to the ocean floor
unknown sea creatures hiding away from
humanity and the general isolation of
the suffocating dark blue the ocean
swallows its victims with all of these
images that come to mind when thinking
about the vast and mysterious depths of
the sea and no one is more familiar with
nautical Mysteries than the SCP
Foundation today we'll be taking a look
at SCP 5007 the bass straight A wave of
oceanic anomalies fit to make any
seasoned sailor shiver in fear the bass
straight is an area of ocean dividing
Tasmania and the Australian Mainland
it's also the location of an unusually
high amount of disappearances Sailors
disappearing from their ships fishermen
leaving in the night and never coming
back even civilians disappearing from
the shores that connect to the straight
the foundation was aware of these
disappearances since 1858 but were only
able to craft theories about what was
causing them was it an anomalous group
of Interest hostile aerial entities
patrolling the skies above the straight
phenomenon associated with unidentified
flying objects what about Subterranean
anomalies weather patterns or time
dilation for nearly a century the
foundation was unable to determine the
cause of the high number of
disappearances in the bass straight and
then the phenomenon suddenly revealed
itself in 1980 on a beach connected to
the straight agent taberer an off
operative of the SCP Foundation was
vacationing with his wife Mary and his
three young children the Taber family
was simply enjoying their day when they
saw what looked like balloons in the sky
they were approaching quickly and
naturally the family moved closer what
happened next was a whirlwind and those
balloons the family were so interested
in Lifted them up from the ground and
carried them away aent Taber tried to
fight back but there was nothing he
could do except report to the foundation
what had occurred occurred and the
organization responded in full force the
foundation's research discovered that
reports of UFOs and lights in the sky
had coincided with many disappearances
in the straight and that this was a
pattern the search for the four lost
Taber family members had become a large-
scale investigation into unexplained
disappearances along the bass straight
and within 3 weeks it was determined
that these patterns were consistent
across the entirety of the Strait's
coastal regions some witnesses were
interviewed but the vast majority of
these abduction cases had no Witnesses
whatsoever of the minimal reports filed
the foundation was told that there were
lights in the sky and that appearance of
unidentified flying objects described as
having the appearances of balloons one
such witness interviewed was a man by
the name of Alan Stewart a witness who
was present during The Disappearance of
former Australian prime minister Harold
Holt whose disappearance the foundation
believed may have had a connection to
the bast Strait anomalies during the
interview steuart claimed that Holt and
his family while voyaging on their yacht
decided to leave the boat and go for a
swim Holt turned to Stuart and asked him
if he could see the balloons around the
cliff steuart had no idea what Holt was
talking about but Holt was insistent on
seeing them he swam deep out into the
ocean saying that they weren't normal
balloons and that there was someone
inside of them steuart and Hal's family
called out for him to come to shore but
he wouldn't listen steuart tried to
rationalize what he saw next maybe it
was the current sweeping h way but he
couldn't lie to the foundation
interviewer Stuart saw Holt go further
and further out into the water and
suddenly the Prime Minister turned
around he began swimming in the opposite
direction and he was screaming suddenly
Holt was lifted from the sea and pulled
into the air by something emerging from
the clouds the foundation thanked Stuart
for the interview and continued their
investigation 2 years later in 1982
Emergency Services received a large
number of calls pertaining to UFO
sightings off the coast of Norman Bay
Victoria the foundation was quick to
respond alerting task forces and local
sites to prepare for an investigation
upon arriving to the scene they
confirmed the existence of multiple
entities that would later be documented
as SCP 57 they evacuated civilians from
the area and successfully managed to
capture the creature which was later
transported to site 40 for containment
it was a sight to Behold The Entity now
designated SCP 500 7- S1 was a cluster
of human bodies fused between a grouping
of black tentacles of varying length
each tentacle was fused to the skin it
touched directly the stomachs of the
corpses were grossly swollen and
distorted to massive sizes to hold large
quantities of gases inside the Bucy of
which The Entity used to achieve a
passive flight across the entity's
surface were clusters of eyes and
bioluminescent glowing organs many of
the humanoid components of the Corpses
appeared to have been removed and
misplaced across various parts of the
entity's body what's more is that the
foundation discovered that human
portions of SCP 5007 appeared somewhat
cognizant and aware of their situation
their vocalizations were incoherent and
barely understandable consisting of
gasping and whimpering but the corpses
were observed to implore other
individuals to approach them when
encountered SCP 57s behavior during
abduction scenarios was documented
during the initial containment event and
and due to the foundation's painstaking
research a pattern was established
between all SCP 5007 encounters first
the victim would be alone or otherwise
vulnerable in a coastal location SCP
5007 haven't shown a preference for
weather be they clear or hostile Skies
but they have localized all of their
activity to the bass straight in small
coastal towns beaches or boats SCP 5007
will then move towards the shore
stalking the victim before lowering its
tentacles and appendages to grab the
individual snatching them into the sky
an SCP 57 instance can even abduct
multiple people at once one event
observed had eight men from the decks of
a commercial fishing boat taken into the
sky in under 15 seconds once captured
SCP 57 instances will Dart across the
water at a high speed and take their
victims to an unknown location
discovering where SCP 5007 took their
victims became a top priority for the
foundation after extensive witness
interviews and compiling a database of
likely victims they determined that
there must be at least 16 instances of
SCP 5007 unaccounted for personnel kept
a close watch on the coastlines and
Waters of the bass straight and equipped
various Marine task forces with research
vessels capable of tracking any
instances if they encountered them in
1985 the foundation's research efforts
paid off and several survey teams
operating in in the area reported a
sighting of an extremely large SCP 5007
instance heading towards a coastal town
a mobile task force was sent to track
the entity the team observed The Entity
from afar as it stocked a private
fishing boat even from the distance
Foundation Personnel recognized the
likenesses of several missing persons as
faces of the corpses of SCP 5007 the
task force Captain had to remind his
team to keep it together claiming that
they were not people but just parts of
the specimen but everyone secretly knew
the truth the fishing vessel was a
private one occupied by a small family
The Entity slowly approached and quickly
pulled a woman into the air the family
panicked and quickly tried to reach
cover for safety running into the Ship's
Cabin The Entity ran its tentacles along
the boat until it pulled the door open
snatching another two victims the task
force was unable to help them as their
mission was to track the instance to its
origin point it was a horror to watch
the task force implanted a tracking
Beacon onto the entity and quietly
followed it out to sea over the next 4
hours they then discovered a large gray
Reef with several shipwrecks dotted
across it 13 SCP 57 instances floated
over the area some holding on to the
land Reef with their tentacles The
Entity dropped the abductees from the
fishing boat who were coerced by the
entities into diving into a massive pool
of water located in the center of the
reef one by one each abduct was pulled
below the surface by something lurking
in the pool all while the SCP 5007
instances watched disgusted the task
force reported what they observed to the
main site and the reef would be
designated as SCP
57- the foundation's analysis of the
reef led to the discovery that The Rock
covering it seeped iron oxide from an
unknown source and the Rocks achieved
growth at an anomalously fast rate often
as little as 40 minutes all of the W
ships and aircraft craft that washed
across the shore of the reef were
covered with a dark stone The Reef was
teaming with anomalous marine life
including SCP 57 a red algae that fed
upon the freshly grown Rock Marine worms
capable of levitation spiders that lived
in silk Retreats underneath the
waterline small fish and giant organisms
resembling large clumps of kelp which
the foundation had previously documented
as SCP 4159 in a separate investigation
SCP 5 7 often rested their tentacles on
the outcroppings of the wath while
inactive but what caught the
foundation's attention the most was the
giant pit located in the reef center
unmanned exploration drones found that
it had a depth of at least 4,000 M and
water samples taken from the pit
revealed large quantities of human DNA
prehistoric bacteria and unknown
compounds that possess significant
life-preserving qualities when a being
was submerged in the compound they were
able to survive heavy injuries even when
fully surrounded by the liquid and
unable to breathe the foundation's
exploration of one of these shipwrecks
LED them to a journal most of it was
illegible due to water damage but one
passage survived located in the back of
the book it detailed the experience of
an unknown crew member of the ship
caught in the storm it reads Mosby spied
land ahead and the boy said that there
are giant balloons hanging over the
island we are all a feared but there is
not we can do but Beach ourselves and
help for rescue should I be killed in
the crash I want my mates to give this
journal to my Mary might know I spent my
last thinking only of her the interior
of the ship contained human remains
inside but there were less skeletons
than the foundation would expect for a
ship of its size the location of the
rest of the bodies was unknown another
event related to SCP 5007 the foundation
documented involved Frederick valentic a
pilot engaged in a training flight over
the bass straet in 1978 valentic
disappearance was marked by his latest
communication with air traffic control
when he mistook an SCP 57 instance for
an unidentified aircraft it seems like
it's stationary what I'm doing right now
is orbiting and the thing is just
orbiting on top of me also it's got a
green light and sort of metallic like
it's all shiny on the outside shortly
after this Valenti's transmission was
interrupted by what was described as
metallic scraping sounds believed to be
the SCP 5007 instance attacking the
aircraft and jamming its propellers with
its mass after crashing into the reef it
was believed that valentic and his
aircraft were pulled beneath the surface
of the pit just as the abductees had
been prior the foundation decided to
construct a provisional secure research
facility on the reef they named it site
40- and documented all returns and
departures of SCP 5007 they also set up
a series of containment procedures that
resulted in SCP 57 returning with its
victims 83% less often than before the
site's Construction but this was
shortlived in 2008 the site logged over
36 instances returning to the reef with
only two not having any fresh abductees
the instance's origins were unknown and
it was as if they appeared out of thin
air no other monitoring post had
documented their appearance or even
spotted them before they arrived at The
Reef it was years later in 2017 that the
foundation eventually was able to
successfully explore what was deep
inside the pit at the center of the reef
they already knew that there was a large
entity lurking beneath as evidence by
what happened to the victims of SCP 5007
that were later deposited inside the
pool all previous attempts to explore
the pool were met with failure as the
water pressure of the Pit's depths
caused all craft to collapse due to Hull
damage this time however they managed to
construct a high-tech submarine labeled
the scps Nautilus which was capable of
diving a maximum of 13,500 M underwater
they decided that a d-class Personnel
would be trained to man The submersible
and carry out the exploration the
mission was simple the Nautilus was to
dive to the bottom of the pit and to
describe the depth readings cameras and
microphones were equipped to the vessel
due to the depth remote viewing of the
footage was impossible instead the
foundation had to physically recollect
the vessel in order to view the footage
upon recovery some of the footage
suffered data corruption but what was
there shook those who viewed it to their
core the footage showed The d-class
Experience going deeper inside the pit
at first it seemed ordinary the trench
had a number of Rocky outcroppings
dotted with black yellow Vines growing
along the walls also present were
various marine life forms such as the
spiders or the fish going deeper the sub
observed an SCP 57 instance clinging to
an outcropping several tendrils emerging
from the Pit's depths were wrapped
around the instance and holding on to
the entity as if it were feeding from it
another 16 SCP 57 instances were seen
resting along the walls each clinging to
the outcropping as the sub went deeper
the d-class remarked that there were
dozens of plane and shipwrecks but also
well over 100 SCP 57 entities most of
them were held there by the black
tendrils the d-class as the sub went
even deeper began noticing human remains
no short amount of them either deep into
the pit there was a large mass of human
remains covering the entirety of the pit
bodies crushed and drained of blood but
still possessing intact eyes each
individual was still alive kept
preserved by the life- sustaining
compounds found within the water the
body stared at the sub and moved
attempting to grab onto the vehicle the
declass swore they were trying to say
something mouthing words to the camera
of the sub as the sub passed through the
mass of bodies it emerged into a
completely dark black clearing at the
bottom of the pit for a second the
declass thought thought he was safe but
then a large black tentacle rapidly
emerged from below and grabbed onto the
Nautilus dragging it even further Into
the Depths the declass screamed and
panicked but there was nothing he could
do the tentacle possessed a large
cluster of eyes mouths and human heads
seemingly grafted onto its mass and then
there was another tentacle and then
another the Nautilus was pulled to the
bottom of the pool the DCL class's
screams were still heard even as the
picture cut out sometimes graphic body
altering images of the tentacles
features were visible on the screen but
most of the footage was indecipherable
after minutes of distorted corrupted
footage the Nautilus was seen again
rapidly ascending to the surface somehow
it had managed to escape the entity at
the bottom of the pit upon recovery of
The Craft it was found that the Nautilus
was covered in a thick organic coating
similar to a black slime mold but with
dozens of eyes growing from it the
d-class inside showed severe
psychological damage and attempt to harm
Foundation Personnel they were
terminated shortly after due to being a
danger to those around them following
review of the footage the Nautilus was
to be dismantled and incinerated along
with the remains of the d-class a
reinforced containment seal was fitted
over the pit with the intention of
keeping whatever was down there isolated
from the surface but this was shortlived
after the containment seal was fitted
site 40 underwent a massive
Communications blackout every device on
site received an email Emil containing a
single image of a large eye taken from a
security camera the text beneath it
simply read found you some Personnel who
viewed the email underwent anomalous
changes growing new physical features
such as eyes and other various growths
across their body the entirety of site
40- went offline and the foundation
could not establish contact in an
emergency effort to do so mobile task
force gamma- 6 deep feeders was sent to
investigate the task Force's assault on
site for 40- was a daring effort as the
majority of the site was completely
overtaken by tentacles growths and
anomalous alterations while numerous
altered Personnel were lost due to the
mission it was ultimately a success some
altered Personnel were able to be saved
through extensive surgery to remove
their anomalous growths and after
everything was said and done the site
was repaired and reconstructed without
incident following the sight's repair
there has been little activity from The
Entity within the pit but the foundation
continued to keep an eye on the creature
and the ecosystem of the anomalous
marine life that live on the bass
straight never knowing what their next
move might be and always keeping in mind
the risk that comes with dealing with
these poorly understood entities a giant
monstrous craba likee claw closes around
the throat of an unimaginably huge
eel-like Beast the beast's terrible
riing tentacles wrap around and latch
onto the immense crustation and then the
high intensity the beams of gamma
radiation start flying all the while
Legions of skinless Centaur swim in the
waters around them relishing the
violence and in the middle a lone boat
the scps mither maned by a team of
mobble task force operatives that does
all it can just to survive there are
those who consider outer space to be the
ultimate achievement in Exploration the
one place that explorers have yet to
chart and understand however some of the
murkiest Mysteries in the universe are
on our own Planet deep down at the
bottom of the ocean 95% of the deep
ocean remains completely unexplored and
the little glimpses we have gotten paint
a picture of something truly alien giant
squids organisms that can breathe
nitrogen luminescent predatory fish and
sharks as old as the Earth itself even
the SCP Foundation is still struggling
to to fully grasp the depth of the ocean
and the strange beings that dwell there
one of the most unusual aquatic findings
in the history of the foundation is that
of SCP
3700 SCP 3700 refers to a circular area
in the North Sea with a diameter of 800
km the waters there are abnormally deep
for the region with the seafloor resting
at 5 km beneath the ocean's surface
there are two entities present in the
waters of SCP 3700 designated SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 interactions between these two
entities are responsible for the
anomalous changes to the meteorological
and geological conditions in the area
SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 always interact on the spring and
fall equinoxes of Any Given year but
they will also engage one another
throughout the year year seemingly at
random but what exactly are SCP
37001 and SCP
37002 aside from terrifying creatures of
the deep SCP 37001 is an arthropod
bearing an aesthetic resemblance to the
European Lobster only much much bigger
measuring 6 km in length the creature is
green with a mix of blue yellow pink and
red markings across the top of its
exoskeleton
that bear the appearance of a woman's
face it has six prehensile limbs four of
which terminate in Claws and eight legs
the entities four eyes are compound and
orange attached to stocks anyone who
gets close enough to observe the
creature's carapace in detail will
notice scars cracks and small holes
indicating years and years of damage SCP
37001 has several anomalous qualities in
addition to its size in a fight it is
able to strike with its appendages and
produce cavitation bubbles with a force
greater than several tons of Dynamite
two of the entities eyes are capable of
blasting concentrated gamma radiation at
a chosen Target the creature has the
ability to impact the weather around it
dispersing storms that impede its
ability to move with ease and can reach
speeds up to 100 km an hour in spite of
its immense power SCP
37001 is not aggressive and tends to
ignore beings in its vicinity other than
SCP
37002 speaking of SCP
37002 it is a 32 km long entity
resembling a pelican eel in all aspects
except for its massive size and the 13
appendages that encircle the middle
section of its body these appendages
which tuck inside its body when not in
use are similar to the tentac I Les of
an octopus complete with suckers the
majority of the entity's body consists
of a seny tail terminating in a sharp
point when its mouth is open it is an
estimated 3 km deep its flesh is black
and it has white purple and red
bioluminescent lines in the shape of a
man's face on either side of its torso
SCP 3700 d2's anomalous properties
include the ability to invoke storms
with a severity of category 5 her
hurricanes and the ability to produce
whirlpools that draw in any vessel
within 150 M so that it can rip them
apart it is also able to produce high
energy sound waves as well as blue fire
which it emits from its esophagus when
the two entities interact it results in
an epic struggle as each begins attempts
to destroy or subdue the other when one
is Victorious immediate changes to the
area follow when SCP 37 100-1 winds the
storms and harsh weather in the area
will immediately calm and an era of
fertility and abundance will begin the
reproductive rates of fauna in the ocean
and on the Islands nearby increase
threefold and the crop yield doubles the
ocean itself becomes increasingly active
and the erosion rates of the
archipelago's shores increase fivefold
when SCP 3700 D2 wins however the
weather conditions become dangerous
with raging hurricanes rapidly
fluctuating temperatures and constantly
changing Storm fronts that cause
destruction of buildings and loss of
life naturally this renders any Ocean
Travel in the area extremely difficult
or even impossible aquatic food sources
are driven Away by harsh conditions and
livestock are killed by exposure and
disease crops are unable to thrive in
the high winds water log soil and lack
of sunlight all the file SCP 37002 swims
throughout the area praying on
unsuspecting ships and menacing the
coastline until SCP 37001 manifests to
challenge it again SCP 37002 will also
regurgitate instances of SCP
3456 though how or why this is possible
is unknown for those unfamiliar with SCP
3456 they are a group of hairless 3
towed horike creatures with thick
translucent skin and human torsos fused
to their backs they are most frequently
seen near sights of War terrorist
attacks and devastating natural
disasters direct observation of one of
these entities will draw their attention
to the Observer who the entity will then
stalk and capture before disappearing
due to their enormous size and ability
to anomalously manifest in their home
Waters SCP
37001 and 2 cannot be contained at a
foundation site instead their
containment is handled by Foundation
Naval task force Delta 7 Northern Storm
who Patrol the area in combination of
refurbished battleships destroyers
Cruisers and support craft additionally
measures have been taken to suppress
information about SCP 3700 among the
general population details about the
unusual depth of the waters there have
been stricken from public texts and
scientific publication
SCP 37001 has been implanted with
donovian Hollow projectors which
disguise it as a pod of humpback whales
if SCP 37001 encounters SCP
37002 Delta 7 May engage protocol winter
Maelstrom this consists of Destroyers
deploying Harpoon based anchors into SCP
3700 d2's head to hold it in one
location next the vessels work together
to Target the ENT entity until SCP 37001
is able to subdue it if this does not
prove effective and SCP 3700 D2 cannot
be contained then the task force will
Implement protocol tumult at this point
Naval and civilian crafts in the area
must be evacuated trade and Ferry routes
to the archipelagos must be rerouted for
at least 6 months there will be constant
aerial and Naval engagement with SCP
37002 and constant monitoring for the
reappear of SCP
37001 the behavior of SCP 37001 and SCP
37002 is largely very predictable with
one notable exception on March 20th 2017
a pair of SCP Foundation owned
battleships known as the mither and the
Teran arrived at a point between the
orne Shetland and Pharaoh archipelagos
in the North Sea they were accompanied
by the usual Fleet of Delta 7 ships
approximately 600 M away away from the
ship's anchor points the water began to
emit intense bright rays of light for a
duration of 3 minutes at this point SCP
37001 appeared visible through the
surface of the water Delta 7 withdrew
their anchors speeding toward the entity
as the ships caught up to the entity it
raised two of its claws into the air
clicking them together in a friendly
greeting the Delta 7 ships followed the
entity along its usual swimming path for
30 minutes and during this time all was
peaceful but this peace did not endure
for long the tide began to change
literally as large black wall clouds
formed overhead the winds picked up and
the waves churned violently in response
as CP 3700 D1 raised its claws overhead
waving them in a circular motion and
parting the clouds above it and Delta 7
but this effort took a lot out of the
creature and after 30 seconds its
antenna began to droop and it lowered
its claws
still the hole in the clouds remained
allowing a spot of sunshine to break
through and beam down on the foundation
vessels 600 M ahead the ocean waters
began to rage and froth spraying foam
and surf into the air SCP 37002 burst
from beneath the surface its head
pointed upward it continued to rise
until the tops of its tentacles could be
seen just above the water then stop to
bend its torso and turn it head
horizontally its jaw unhinged exposing
rows upon rows of serrated teeth the
Beast let out a mighty Roar accompanied
by a stream of blue flame at the sight
of its rival SCP 37001 Dove beneath the
surface disappearing from view the scps
mither ordered the rest of the vessels
to engage protocol winter Maelstrom
delta7 scattered out from SCP 3700 d1's
point of submersion and all 13
destroyers fired their harpoons at SCP
37002 embedding themselves in the
entity's head naturally this enraged the
creature and it began to Roar and whale
spinning its lower body vigorously
enough to generate a Whirlpool the
Cruisers opened fire with a combination
of L cannons and conventional Weaponry
in order to distract The Entity as the
Destroyers pulled their Harpoon lines TT
dragging its head in a continuous Circle
while this was taking place the
battleships got into position I and
prepared to fire on the mither's Mark 3
2 1 fire the first broadside barrage
collided with SCP 3700 D2 and it grunted
in pain thrashing back and forth before
opening its mouth and spewing an
instance of SCP 3456 into the water as
soon as it hit the water the eoin
monster began to cut through at a pace
of 50 km an hour making its way toward
the Destroyers particularly the SCP yes
skki the skki attempted to retarget its
weapons and prevent the creature from
reaching it but the monster moved too
quickly for the skky to adjust the sky
was lifted out of the water by the
creature as crew members desperately
clung to the railings and their Weaponry
as the crew cowered and tried to fend
off the creature it reached for them
trying to pull them from the ship while
the sky was occupied SCP 37-2 was able
to attack again blasting another ship
with a stream of blue fire allow crack
rang out from across the sea as the sky
dropped back into the water the SCP 3456
instance shrieking in pain SCP 3700 D1
burst through the surface striking the
creature with its Club likee limbs each
blow emitting another loud crack the
third blow tore the instance in half
sending its human torso kening through
the air and pass the scps mither freed
from its attack the CI moved full steam
ahead pulling the Harpoon line Tau again
and dragging SCP
37002 out of its path several silky crew
members were thrown overboard during the
struggle and as they struggled to keep
their heads above water SCP 37001
scooped them up placing them onto the
deck of a nearby destroyer and out of
Harm's Way with the crew members rescued
SCP 37001 set its sights on its enemy
swimming towards the edge of the
whirlpool and emitting a luminescent
glow from two of its eyes the con
barrage of cannon fire on SCP 37002 was
beginning to take its toll and the
myther ordered the fleet to quote brace
for the killing blow as if responding to
the mither's call SCP 37001 shot several
concentrated blasts of gamma radiation
at its foe leaving large holes in the
creature in their wake SCP 37002
screamed flailing so hard that it
snapped the Harpoon lines and created
waves large enough to push the vessels
backward with its Newfound Freedom SCP
3700 D2 impaled SCP 37001 through the
midsection with its Barbed tip of its
tail lifting it up and out of the water
with the force of the blow SCP 37001
desperately trying to free itself
attacking the tail with its Club likee
limbs but the fight was in vain and
after a moment all movement stopped SCP
37001 was for at least the duration of
this manifestation dead SCP 37002 tossed
the corpse into the water flinging it
past Delta 7 where it crashed into the
water and sank down Into the Depths
below at this point Delta 7 was ordered
to initiate protocol tumult the Delta 7
vessels turned away from SCP
37002 and prepared to evacuate the area
one of the ships the scps strosin Beast
slowed behind the rest of the fleet
emitting concerning amounts of smoke
before coming to a stop meanwhile the
enraged and emboldened SCP 3700 D2
expanded the size of its Whirlpool
setting its sights on the retreating
ships and the weakened strawy Beast the
ship tried to flee but the engines were
completely shot and would not respond
the ship was caught in the whirlpool and
pulled against its will toward SCP
37002 as the crew looked on in helpless
dread a tentacle Rose from the deep
wrapping around the vessel and dragging
it toward the entity escaping ma
suddenly SCP 37001 exploded from beneath
the surface of the water leaping between
the ship and SCP 3700 D2 cutting the
tentacle in half and freeing the sty
beast from its grip SCP 3700 D2 shrieked
before closing its jaws and biting down
on SCP
37001 it retaliated emitting bright
flashes of light and doing enough damage
to stop SCP 3700 D2 from continuing to
produce its Whirlpool another tentacle
emerged from the water pulling at SCP
3700 d1's legs and ripping them from its
body but SCP 37001 returned the assault
in kind bludgeoning SCP 37002 with its
Club likee limbs from inside of its
mouth all at once SCP 3700 d2's lower
jaw was torn out of place dropping into
the water with SCP 37001 still inside
SCP 37002 thrashed fuly growing steadily
weaker and weaker it released one more
stream of fire before collapsing Delta 7
paused The Retreat watching the scene
for any sign of a winner but after 5
minutes neither entity had moved Delta 7
returned to the side of the battle to
investigate and saw that neither entity
was moving and both appeared to be
deceased shortly after Delta 7 reached
the area both entities disappeared
leaving a single round unidentified
object object that sank below the
surface where SCP
37001 had just been the wall clouds
overhead dispersed leaving standard cumo
nimbus clouds in their place the waters
themselves remain choppy unsure of how
to proceed the scps mither sent a radio
transmission to command uh this is Delta
7 to command we read you Delta 7 command
replied we have a bit of a situation go
ahead Delta 7 SCP
37001 and two are B
down command was silent for 10 seconds
utterly baffled by the information
please repeat Delta 7 again the myther
said SCP
3700-3 are both down command ordered the
mither to stand by 3 minutes of radio
silence later communication resumed as
they asked are either entity's effects
active ah negative command is there any
trace of either entity also negative it
appears the anomaly has been neutral
neutralized Delta 7 is to return to base
for debrief following any recovery
efforts with their next steps clear
Delta 7 attached these strawy bees to
several tugboats preparing to pull the
vessel to safety but there was one more
surprise waiting the scps mither began
picking up unusual levels of gamma
radiation as well as a sonar contact at
a depth of 3 km they called command
requesting permission to deploy
submersibles for exploration purposes 1
minute of Silence followed as the the
command arrived at a decision request
denied return to base for debriefing and
so Delta 7 began to evacuate the area
once more steaming in the opposite
direction of the battle over the next 5
minutes CCTV cameras on the vessels
picked up an unusual sight as the gamma
radiation levels continued to increase
the ocean turbulence also worsened
tossing smaller vessels and nearly
causing them to capsize then all of a
sudden the water stilled and four large
yellow orbs appeared below the surface
approximately 300 M from Delta 7 they
lingered there for 2 minutes before
Vanishing afterward a new sonar contact
was detected 5 km deep directly beneath
the task force command we've lost the
signal from the previous contact and are
no longer detecting gamma radiation uh
we're detecting new contact 5 km deep
large in metallic after further
deliberation command responded Delta 7
you are authorized to deploy submers I
for exploration purposes we advise
should SCP 37002 manifest exploration
teams are to be considered lost and you
are to return to base the consequences
of this incident as well as what else
might be lurking down in the depths
beneath SCP 3700 are still unknown Dr
reard had lost everything his job the
respect of his peers and if everyone
else was right perhaps even his mind it
was 11:00 p.m. m. when he staggered to
the edge of Okanagan Lake in British
Columbia eyes and judgment clouded with
booze this Lake could have been what
made his career as a researcher for the
SCP Foundation but now that bright
future was slipping through his fingers
like the dry silt beneath his feet he
looked hatefully across the endless dark
surface of the water and loudly cursed
stupid empty place just hours ago he'd
been stripped of his ranks and released
from his position at the foundation for
wasting the organization's time and
resources on frivolous personal projects
frivolous he thought what a terrible
joke just because the higher-ups refused
to acknowledge what was going out here
didn't mean it wasn't there Moonlight
shimmered off the water's surface wait
was that Moonlight or was there
something lurking underneath the water
to truly answer this question if any
answer is possible at all we need to go
back to the beginning and ask ourselves
a different question how does the SCP
Foundation actually find most of the
anomalies it cataloges and contains it
is a simple question with a multifaceted
answer depending on the anomaly in
question for the most part the
foundation has a network of field agents
embedded in pretty much every
institution across the globe including
rival groups of Interest like the global
occult Coalition and the Serpent's hand
if they so much as sniff the strange and
unusual they alert the nearest site
director and the necessary Personnel are
dispatched to the scene there's also the
foundation web crawlers which are a form
of specialized software constantly
patrolling the web for anomalous
activity that the foundation wants to
know about and one of the rarer but
still incredibly important methods of
finding a scps involve looking into
myths and local Legends sure it may seem
like a good way to waste time and
resources but the crossover between
recorded scps and folklore is
surprisingly common take SCP 1000 the
formerly hyper intelligent Apes that
were nearly the dominant species on
Earth until humans and a certain
capricious Forest God pulled the dirty
trick on them they're better known to
most civilians as the legendary Bigfoot
or Sasquatch perhaps the most famous
crypted of all time or SCP 1337 The
Hitchhiker an anomalous spectral entity
that manifests in the cars of those who
don't pick her up and performs horrific
acts of violence against them she's
eerily similar to Legends you can find
not only all over the us but the entire
world of ghostly hitchhikers intruding
into the cars of unwary Travelers and
scaring them half to death or worse if
you're unlucky another case where myths
and legends pointed the SCP Foundation
in exactly the right direction and of
course there's SCP 136 the terrifying
naked doll this was an almost
featureless children's doll found inside
an abandoned house but prolonged time in
its presence can make you the victim of
a warped Apparition that'll drive you
half mad with fear it's got such a
detrimental psychological effect on
people that the foundation has been
controversially using it as a torture
method during enhanced interrogation
sessions with captured members of rival
groups of interest and how did they find
it the foundation keeps track of
neighborhood rumors about haunted houses
with supposedly Supernatural inhabitants
clearly when it looks like it might
actually get results no myth or local
Legend is too big or too small to
Warrant an investigation from the SCP
Foundation it was with this mindset that
a younger happier and less Dr B Renard
set off with his team to Okanagan Lake
in search of what locals had referred to
as the legendary Ogo Pogo we've all
heard of the Loch Ness monster the lake
monster from Scotland that's been
turning heads for the better part of a
century and may be related to two other
similar s scps namely SCP 3934 and SCP
5533 but Ogo poo is Canada's answer to
good old Nessie while the Loch Ness
monster resembles a plaur the Yogo is
much more Serpentine with a long coiling
body covered in green scales its long
tail is said to be able to create Fierce
storms along the surface of the water
with its vicious whips killing scores of
unfortunate adventurers who dared stray
too close the name Ogopogo is also a
palindrome meaning it reads the same
forwards as it does backwards and is
believed to have originated in the
novelty from the year
1924 however it's likely that the actual
Beast this somewhat Goofy name was given
to is a much older fiercer entity and
for the sake of his reputation as a
researcher as he took a plane to the
Okanagan Valley Dr rard very much hoped
this was the case of course he'd
explored the Legends heavily so much so
that he was sure there had to be
something to this whole thing the schwep
mech and celix peoples the lake dwelling
monster was known as nit Taka which has
been Loosely translated into the sacred
creature of the water the water God and
most menacing of all the water demon the
Beast was often described in oral
Traditions as being a malicious
Supernatural entity with great power and
ill intent towards those trespassing on
its territory Legend has it that anyone
who crosses Okanagan Lake the supposed
domain of the Ogopogo needs to make a
sacrifice to the monster in order to
ensure safe passage those who refuse to
give this sacrifice the Beast demanded
would pay a heavy toll being devoured or
dragged down to a watery grave never to
be seen again and this monster isn't
just some old folk tale either
contemporary sightings have dated back
to 1873 with both settlers and First
Nations people alike spotting the
Sinister Ogopogo in the intervening
years Dr reard had poured through the
files on hundreds of sightings there
were a number of incidents in the 1980s
so much so that the environmentalist
group Greenpeace moved to have the
creature classified as a protected
species naturally official sources
decided against the idea claiming that
none of the sightings were of substance
in 1992 a vast shape filmed under the
murky water in Okanagan Lake was
suggested to be the legendary beast
however the FBI stepped in to deny the
validity of this case stating that the
Beast was much more likely to be debris
falling off a local tree disappointing
lovers of the strange and unusual
everywhere in 2011 nearly 20 years years
later there was more video footage of a
sighting showing large dark shapes
moving underneath the surface of the
Okanagan Lake however this claim was
once again dismissed by all outside
parties claiming the shape of the Beast
underneath the water was more likely to
be a pair of logs bummer 2018 was an
exciting year for the yoogo with three
different sightings of the creature
being reported at different times
throughout the year Witnesses describe
the creature as being a giant snake
around 50 ft long which is consistent
with with a lot of the historical
descriptions of the Beast as well as
being over twice as long as the
reticulated python the non-anomalous
longest snake in the world so naturally
authority figures once again shot down
the validity of any claims that the
creature was actually real and out there
Dr reard found this almost funny they
didn't even need to suppress knowledge
of this creature if it really was out
there mainstream sources seemed to be
doing their job for them and keeping the
creature covered up he was determined
though that he would be the one to prove
to his superiors that this creature was
indeed real and lurking in Okanagan Lake
he organized a number of varied
investigative missions from actively
trolling the lake itself to conducting
interviews with firsthand witnesses as
well as those who claimed to see no
merit in their evidence and testimony Dr
reard noticed a strange phenomenon the
people who'd seen it firsthand were as
certain that it was real as the doubters
were that it was fake even for typical
Skeptics the non-believers seemed
shockingly Resolute that there was
really nothing down there and the
alleged photos and videos were 100%
bogus early diagnostic tests into the
lake directly overseen by Dr Renard
seemed to point to a creature clearly
being down there he found the direct
testimony both compelling and consistent
with what he and his team were catching
glimpses of so why were people so
adamant that nothing was down there it
was almost like the yoogo really was as
mythical as the First Nations Legends
said and was casting a spell on all the
non-believers that's when it hit Dr
Renard like a perfect bolt of lightning
they weren't just looking at a
particularly large sea snake with
unnatural longevity here they were
looking at a sea serpent with Cognito
hazardous Powers it was a beast with a
perfect defense mechanism only those who
sought up close would actually believe
that the creature was real anyone who
found out about it via secondary sources
would experience an extreme state of
incredulity nobody except those who
sought Direct ly would ever believe that
it existed and thus even the most
intelligent prey would lower their
defenses around its domain an elegant
and dangerous anomalous Hunter Dr rard
had found himself a worthy opponent and
one that would help him make his Mark at
the foundation he drew up the file and
gave it the designation SCP 1933 before
sending it back to his supervisors they
wrote back saying that they didn't feel
as though there was enough of a basis in
evidence to deem this entry worthy of
inclusion if Dr Renard wanted to have
his so-called Ogopogo dignified with
entry into the SCP Foundation archives
he needed to back it up properly this
presented a problem to Dr Renard how
could he provide documentation and
evidence for a creature that had the
defining anomalous power of making all
of its own documentation and evidence
seem phony he was caught between a rock
and a hard place with only one solution
create the most undeniably highquality
evidence of the creature that the world
had ever seen scene not long after that
his superiors at the SCP Foundation
would receive a video file from Dr rard
according to the notes on his report he
set up a track using an ALK carcass to
lure the creature out of the water and
capture HD video of its feeding when the
senior researchers gathered around to
watch the video they were astounded an
animatronic a cheap rubber suit around a
somewhat janky robot like something
you'd see at a theme park how much had
Dr rard spent on this absurd farce did
think it was funny despite Dr Renard's
protests he was reprimanded severely for
this waste of foundation resources the
object class on his 1933 file was
switched to explained meaning a rational
nonanomalous explanation for The
observed phenomenon had been found
discrediting it and the 1933 slot was
instead filled with a strange fat man
dressed as Santa Claus whose bodily
fluids are all Irish Cream the ultimate
humiliation Dr rard was left with
nothing and we join him once again where
we started with Dr Renard standing on
the ledge of Okanagan Lake staring
hatefully into the water as something
seemed to move underneath if Dr rard
screamed that night there was nobody
there to hear it his remains were
dredged out of the lake the next day His
official cause of death was listed as
drowning after an unfortunate boating
accident though the boat in question was
never found reports that his corpse was
found half eaten have mostly been
dismissed as rumors after all there is
no such thing as the
Ogopogo water the Wellspring of Life
we've dealt with a number of anomalous
water sources on this channel like SCP
006 the much sought after Fountain of
Youth or the terrifying SCP 3280 where
murderous water threatens to destroy the
entire world but we've never seen
anomalous water that behaves quite like
this before in many of the legends of
King Arthur the sword of Excalibur is
presented to him by the mystical Lady of
the Lake this lady emerges from the
depths of the water gifting Arthur with
the enchanted sword it's an incredible
if impossible image a woman appearing
from within the lake rising up from the
bottom and breaking through the surface
it's safe to say that none of us have
ever seen anything quite like it well at
least most of us haven't in a small
unnamed English Village there was a
young woman who out on a particularly
lovely warm spring day to take a swim in
a nearby lake while waiting in the water
enjoying the sunlight and the gentle
breeze on her skin she saw a strange
Ripple ghost across the surface she
stopped her swimming staring at the
motion she expected to spot a fish or
some other aquatic creature instead the
water itself began to rise up gathering
in forming into a shape before her eyes
it was impossible and yet here it was
happening she pinched herself and found
that she was definitely awake as the
water transformed into the shape of a
human woman it turned to look at her
shimmering eyes finding hers and liquid
lips forming into a warm inviting smile
though this being was shocking to see it
clearly meant her no harm it raised a
translucent arm and gave her a small
wave as if to welcome her to its home
the young woman approached this Lady of
the Lake reaching out her own hand of
Flesh and bone to touched this
Impossible Creature just as her
fingertips reached the water woman's Z
the figure dissolved back into the lake
with a splash the young woman ran home
telling anyone who would listen about
the incredible things she had seen that
day of course no one believed her that
is until word of her sighting reached
the only people who might take her
claims seriously the SCP Foundation they
sent operatives to the lake where they
managed to capture the shape-shifting
entity dwelling there SCP 054 also known
as the water nymph is a being made up
entirely of water with an average volume
of 90 L when it is out of a body of
water the being tends to adopt the
appearance of a humanoid woman though it
is capable of taking on a variety of
other shapes including other humanoids
animals and various inanimate objects
The Entity is also capable of shedding
its form and effectively disappearing
into a given body of water in order to
avoid shrinking or possibly disappearing
entirely from evaporation ation SCP 054
is required to return to a larger body
of water studies of samples taken from
the entity's body or its version of a
body revealed that it is made up of
ordinary water there is no apparent
reason for its ability to move and no
thermal electromagnetic biological or
Supernatural anomalies were detected the
research team could not determine what
might make this water alive and sentient
and the nature of its unusual properties
is uncertain to this day when CP 054 was
first brought into containment at site
08 it displayed surprisingly congenial
and curious Behavior often walking
around outside of the water and taking
turns mimicking the shapes of various
staff and scientists that spoke to it
its demeanor began to shift towards
suspicion and aggression however
following a series of experiments and an
incident involving the research staff
the first experiment conducted on SCP
054 sought to determine what would
happen if the entity was denied access
to any fresh water water was drained
from the fountain holding it leaving
only enough water for it to form a
humanoid shape but no additional water
in the Basin to compensate for the
effects of evaporation over time SCP 054
became visibly frustrated as the water
was being drained out of its enclosure
for the next few days it
enthusiastically greeted anyone who
entered its containment facility
attempting to use a report and sense of
familiarity to convince the person to
provide it with more water after it
realized that this approach had no
impact on the amount of water water in
its Fountain it became distant and even
called to anyone who attempted to speak
to it 054 only became friendly again
once the water in its Fountain was
restored to a pre-experiment level next
the research team opted to test SCP 054
reaction to extreme temperatures
particularly extreme cold the
temperature of the containment facility
was slowly dropped until the room fell
below the freezing point of water as the
temperature dropped 054 became sluggish
and exhausted it lost it ability to
shift between forms remaining locked in
its preferred humanoid female shape its
movements slowed more and more as the
room grew colder until the entity was
completely frozen solid portions of the
ice were chipped off and studied
revealing the crystals were identical to
those of ordinary ice after the Sub-Zero
testing the research team decided to
take things to the other end of the
spectrum and test the effects of heat on
SCP 054 the subject was placed in a tank
outfitted with heating equipment
and its temperature was slowly raised
over the course of several minutes when
the water reached a temperature of 95°
the entity's behavior became frenetic
and aggressive it pounded on the glass
walls of the tank and attempted to break
through the lid in a desperate bid for
escape until the temperature was
returned to a comfortable level after
the extreme temperature experiments the
previous calm and Cooperative nature of
SCP 054 was nowhere to be found this
subject displayed increased suspicion of
the research team and would fight back
whenever it was removed from its
Fountain and taken to a lab for
experimentation in spite of this new
found resistance the team decided to
continue their experiments as planned
hoping that the entity would return to
its formerly docile self over time next
Dr cesal the acting head of the research
team conducted a study involving SCP 054
memory and ability to be conditioned The
Entity was presented with a series of
increasingly complex mazes and puzzles
when it failed to comply with the
experiment or solved a puzzle
incorrectly The Entity was punished with
an electrical shock or the release of
silica gel into its body both of these
options seemed to cause it a great deal
of pain and distress and it was eager to
avoid further exposure to them SCP 054
displayed impressive learning and
problem solving capabilities revealing
it is likely much more intelligent than
it was first presumed to be Dr ccll
observing the experiments and with the
effectiveness of his somewhat unsavory
motivational techniques equipped to his
research assistant that they would have
it trained to fetch in no time after
several days of these experiments and
repeated use of both the silica gel and
electrical shocks the entity's progress
slowed down considerably and it became
visibly exhausted it was removed from
the lab for a 48h hour rest period
before experimentation was resumed yet
again this time Dr cesco planned to
expose SCP 054 water source to various
levels of acids and bases in order to
test its homeostatic capabilities be
beginning with a5m solution of
hydrochloric acid prior to conducting
the experiment Dr cesal noted I have no
idea what will happen but if this thing
incorporates homeostatic mechanisms like
I suspect then we should get some
insight into how it maintains its form
he also noted that SCP 054 Behavior was
becoming increasingly erratic but made
the decision to continue with the
experiment as planned SCP 054 displayed
a now familiar reluctance when it was
removed from its containment chamber and
taken to the lab it thrashed around in
the fountain splashing researchers with
water and retreated from them as they
approached in spite of its efforts
however it was removed from its Fountain
and placed in the experimental tank the
solution of hydrochloric acid was then
dripped into the tank and then all hell
broke loose as soon as the acid touched
the surface of its water SCP 054 became
incredibly distressed it Formed into the
shape of a human face eyes wide mouth
open in a Silent Scream of Rage age and
pain the water churned so aggressively
that the lid of the tank was shaken
loose allowing it to escape the
boundaries of its containment the water
formed into two large hands which shot
out of the tank and grabbed the two
nearest researchers pulling them into
the water and exposing their skin to the
acid now present there as the men
scrambled to drag themselves back out of
the tank and their colleagues were busy
helping them SCP 054 took on its usual
humanoid form and ran for the door it
then collapsed into a puddle slipped
under the crack and the bottom of the
door and made its way down the hall it
was apprehended roughly 10 minutes after
its Escape by a team of guards who froze
it using canisters of liquid nitrogen
and then carried its icy body back to
the containment facility the two
researchers who had been pulled into the
tank experienced chemical burns on their
skin as well as significant mental
distress they were given immediate
medical attention and placed on a leave
of absence and all experimentation on
SCP 054 was suspended until further
notice at the recommendation of Dr ccll
04's object class was changed to uid SCP
054 is currently contained in a
watertight isolation room fitted with
climate control equipment a beautiful
intricately designed Fountain has been
placed in the center of the containment
room filled with fresh spring water in
order to accommodate the entity's
environmental needs all maintenance
workers assigned to the area must wear
NBC suits while inside and must spend 10
minutes isolated in a drawing room After
exiting before they are permitted to
return to the rest of the facility if
054 breaches containment the area must
be evacuated and the containment chamber
will be filled with liquid nitrogen in
order to freeze its water solid as the
entity is highly sensitive to the
conditions of the water that houses it
chemical levels and volume of the water
in the fountain must be monitored on a
regular basis and kept at optimal levels
for the health of SCP 054 during the
course of its containment following the
incident around the acid base
incorporation experiment Z 054 has
developed a distrust of men as the
researchers handling that experiment
were primarily male in order to prevent
future incidents and keep SCP 054 calm
no male staff are to be assigned to the
team monitoring its containment unit
because 5 years have passed since the
last incident involving SCP 054 its
object class has been changed from uclid
to safe on the recommendation of the
lead researcher assigned to its case of
course caution should still be exercised
while interacting with The Entity this
is the SCP Foundation after all and just
because a moderate amount of water is
good for you doesn't mean you can't
still drown experimentation on SCP 054
has resumed though this time its
boundaries are being honored and it is
allowed adequate time to rest and
recuperate between experiments all use
of punishment in order to motivate The
Entity has been suspended as it has
shown itself to be more than willing to
cooperate if it is treated with respect
like all of us it responds far better to
kindness than it does to fear and
intimidation it doesn't just take on the
appearance of a person it has thoughts
feelings and the urge to defend itself
when threatened so think twice next time
you find yourself swimming in a random
body of water you should be mindful of
what might be living in there not just
of the fish the algae and the tiny water
bugs but of the invisible intelligent
impossible creatures that might be
swimming in there with you or even make
up the very water itself it was a
beautiful day in Sardinia the second
largest Italian island in the
Mediterranean the sea was clear the air
was hot and the beaches were golden but
the kagari diving Club couldn't see any
of that they were roughly 250 M
underneath the Mediterranean Sea given
the rich and extensive history of the
area they were sure to find some
interesting historical artifacts on the
ocean floor and they were indeed about
to find something incredible but this
history wasn't quite as dead as some old
Roman Pottery Paulo bonacell the most
experienced diver was the deepest of all
they decided to be a little more
ambitious this time than in previous
Dives 20 mi off the Sardinian Coast for
Paulo it was Uncharted Territory so you
could only imagine how amazed and
delighted he was when he saw the shape
of what seemed like a small town beneath
the water Old Stone buildings and a
classic Roman or Grecian Style with
roofs made of thatched seaweed he
gestured to his fellow divers to follow
him they were amazed at how well
preserved the buildings seemed to be as
though they were still being lived in
and actively maintained to this day
despite being around 300 M underwater if
they were able to take some pictures and
collect some artifacts they'd be the
talk of the local historic community and
probably be able to finagle a payout
from the whole experience too that's
when Paulo spotted something truly
amazing a larger more impressive
structure like a miniature Palace
surrounded by grandio statues of
humanoid figures in a circle around the
little Palace each of the statues was an
imposing 5 m tall with a faint Golden
Light emanating from each of them while
the statues were humanoid they
definitely weren't human their features
were strange and fish-like
scales gills tentacles was in awe at the
sight of them he took pictures and got
closer there was also a huge chasm in
front of the building perhaps some kind
of underwater thermal vent Paulo was
curious he wanted to investigate further
he swam deeper and deeper what was at
the bottom of that Chasm but lucky for
Paulo he would never see what was at the
bottom of that Chasm before he could
reach it something intercepted him from
the side something large and fast he
felt a white hot flash of pain as Claus
raked across his chest tearing open the
rubber of his wet suit Paulo turned eyes
widening in horror to see a creature
staring at him like the statues it was
humanoid but not human an
anthropomorphic sea monster with
greenish skin its arms and legs coated
in thin scales its neck serrated into
fleshy gills he could see scraps of his
suits rubber hanging from its claws it
bore a mouthful of fangs and gave a
silent but threatening snarl Paulo could
see something in the distance behind
this creature more figures like this one
emerging from The Merc getting faster
getting closer Pao was a smart man but
it didn't take a genius to realize that
if he stuck around something terrible
was about to happen to him and the rest
of the kagari diving Club he turned and
fled paddling with all his might away
from the coming Legion of aquatic beasts
the rest of the club saw the experienced
diver panic in and followed his lead
thanks to their quick thinking and
expertise they all managed to escape
with their lives and only a few minor
injuries but they had no idea of the
true extent of the mystery they were
leaving behind beneath the sea the
Multiverse is a big place there are
alternate universes where the devour of
Worlds escapes and destroys everything
we love and hold dear there are
alternate universes where the SCP
Foundation has gone haywire and
attempted to wipe out Humanity through
control old releases of all their
anomalies there are even universes where
a kill Squad sent by the chaos
Insurgency hunts down and assassinates
every member of the 05 Council before
replacing them and leading the
foundation into a bold New Era and there
are some universes where the SCP
Foundation is Italian we've covered SCP
057 on this channel before in our video
on the most frightening rooms in the SCP
universe but you've never seen this SCP
057 because this is the Italian version
SCP 057 it this localized anomaly off
the coast of Sardinia is under the
purview of the Italian division of the
SCP Foundation which works autonomously
with its own systems and terminology
this SCP is in a frightening room that
crushes its trapped victims together
this anomaly is an entire city 300 M
beneath the water of the Mediterranean
Sea everyone has heard of the mythical
lost city of Atlantis a supposed
underwater Utopia outlined by such great
historical Minds as the ancient Greek
philosopher Plato it's something that
people fantasize about a beautiful
idyllic Society Under the Sea divorce
from all the petty squabbles we deal
with up on land but is everything really
better down where it's wetter let's take
a look and see when Paulo and the rest
of the kagari diving Club returned to
the surface they were happy to tell
anyone that would listened that they
encountered aggressive merman and an
entire underwater city off the coast of
Sardinia they even posted their photos
onto their official Facebook page along
with photos of Paulo's gnarly chest
scars that's when the Italian branch of
the SCP Foundation finally discovered
them and decided to intervene the
foundation dispatched an sir Squad known
as Oria Nota SS are the intelligence and
research section of the Italian SCP
Foundation a kind of mobile task force
that investigates possible informational
leads Paulo and his team were given
amnestic treatment and any evidence that
they'd collected was scrubbed from
existence meanwhile Lieutenant Marco
levini leader of the mobile task force
ssm2 Squad AKA leio Alanis was being
dispatched to the source of the problem
SCP
057 itself what started off as a
relatively straightforward exploratory
Mission soon took an extremely strange
turn lini and his men reported activity
down in the underwater city observing
from the safety of their armored
Foundation submarine while the Aquatic
humanoids living in 057 it were
undeniably the same species their
culture seemed to be split up into two
unique groups one group had thinner
scales on their arms and legs this group
was more numerous having at least 60
active specimens and was characterized
by their extreme aggression towards any
Outsiders as for the smaller group they
had thicker scales as well as a number
of eily consistent injuries to their
hands feet and gills they were also
distinct from the thin scales in terms
of behavior as they were a far
friendlier more Curious bunch at times
members of this subset would approach
the submarine and regard it with
detached Fascination sometimes they
would even point at the submarine and
laugh though their reasons for doing
this are unknown eventually Lieutenant
levini was so confident in their safety
around the the myr people that he and a
few other team members decided to
disembark from the submarine on a diving
Excursion and properly explore the
Aquatic City below this would prove to
be a dangerous tactical error on lini's
part during what seemed like a routine
exploratory mission lavini was ambushed
by a squadron of thin scales grabbed
from behind and kidnapped he was taken
as a hostage and Spirited Away into one
of the city's various buildings where a
thick scale known as Letizia acted as
his Warden but lini soon found that
being under Leia's care was a profoundly
lucky turn of events on his part both
because it allowed him to learn more
about the situation and because she was
one of the small group left in the city
who hadn't become dangerous Fanatics
that's right the myr people were in the
middle of a heated Civil War both from
the observations of lavini during his
captivity and later interviews conducted
by project head Dr jeppi pastillo with
some liberated members of the thick
scales they they learned that a terrible
religious conflict had broken out in SCP
057 the accounts coming from the rescued
citizens Illustrated a similar backstory
to what the Italian Foundation had
theorized regarding the myrr people they
were the descendants of people that
lived on the island of nisos up to the
14th century BCE before it was
devastated by a volcanic eruption
forcing them into the ocean where they
evolved the ability to live in aquatic
environments through anomalous means
since this change this new species had
been operating in Mediterranean Waters
migrating regularly in order to avoid
detection passing their way of life from
generation to generation as the world
changed and shifted above them in many
ways they were quite similar to humans
such as their reproductive habits they
mate and reproduce after a gestation
period more like animals than fish
though their gestation period is
slightly shorter than human beings at 6
months they largely speak Latin though
the oldest my person among them also
speaks ancient Greek myr children born
in Foundation containment have shown
strong language acquisition skills as
they have proven more than able to learn
modern Italian and even more fascinating
from a standpoint of sociological study
the myr people have formed their own
unique culture under the sea and this is
where the problems started abstaining
from the belief of the Greek and Roman
pantheons their ancestors looked up to
to the myr people instead worshiped
their own group of water-bound deities
whose images were reflected in the great
statues in the center of the town the
large building near the statues and the
chasm was the home of the mayor the
town's de facto leader however what had
been a workable system for centuries
began falling to ruin when a strange
religious fanaticism began to spread a
catlike group soon formed and began
holding ceremonies where they worshiped
a powerful entity in the chasm known as
as the great eye this new cult was known
as The Cult of the great eye of the
Mediterranean or sejam for short what
began as a fringe belief soon became a
frenzy and took over the better part of
the town with the acolytes of the great
eye proving themselves more than willing
to spread the gospel of their new deity
with violence some of the more arduan
non-believers were killed for their hery
While others were simply ritualistically
mutilated in order to prevent them from
rebelling letisia had her own evidence
of these targeted mutilations the thin
scales had cut the Aquatic webbing from
between her fingers and toes making it
harder for her to swim away and Escape
other suspected Heretics were given the
same treatment the reason the thick
scales even had thicker scales was that
they stole forbidden technology from the
mayor to increase the strength of their
scales hoping it would help them better
withstand the torments of the acolytes
those involved in the stealing of this
technology were captured and so
summarily executed for their acts of
defiance in a sense Letizia was
protecting lavini by advising him
against trying to escape knowing the
acolytes of the great eye would kill him
if he did she knew that the only
opportunity for escape would come during
the ceremony held by the acolytes to
honor their frightening Master when the
day eventually came as lavini was
running low on everything from food to
oxygen everyone in the town was forced
out into the Town Center to witness the
ritual the acolytes gathered around the
chasm and began to chant in a
frightening unknown language as they
chanted a blinding light began to
eminate from the chasm and as blurry
shapes emerged nightmarish tentacled
gastropod soon began to take form truly
lovecraftian undersea monsters shortly
after the ritual the Vinnie and the
thick scales were able to make a break
for it pursued by the acolytes of the
great eye it was a close one but
thankfully due to the intervention and
assistance of a trained mobile task
force the fanatical forces of the
acolytes were repelled and the fleeing
myr people along with lavini were
rescued a number of thick scales are now
willingly confined at site netuno an
Italian Foundation containment site
where they have undergone numerous
interviews with Foundation staff
incidentally among them is the oldest
myr person previously present in SCP
057 the only one who spoke ancient Greek
fluently he was different from the
others EXT extremely different in fact
he was a deity made into flesh one of
the deities replaced by the worshippers
of the great eye this unfortunate former
God had done everything to keep his
people's lives safe and peaceful but in
spite of his wisdom and best efforts
hell had once again broken loose not
everything is all well and good in SCP
057 it even if a human's body changes
their nature does not and the worst
parts of human nature seemingly followed
these unfortunate myrr people into what
should have been their Paradise under
the sea but all hope isn't lost if you
were to judge the entire human race on
one community in turmoil you probably
wouldn't leave with a very favorable
impression of us either correspondence
with a French branch of the SCP
Foundation reveals that myr creatures
aren't just localized to one Waring
underwater city in Sardinia mermaids
have also been discovered and confirmed
by Foundation field agents off the coast
of France 80% of the oceans Still
Remains unmapped to this day who knows
what else is out there just waiting to
be found hello SCP Foundation Personnel
welcome to Cognito hazards and you
episode rejected this video series is
intended to teach you about the protocol
surrounding the various Cognito
hazardous anomalies currently within
Foundation containment when you know
better you do better and both you and
the secrets of our great organization
can stay safe and as anyone familiar
with a good Cognito Hazard can tell you
knowing really can make a difference
today's episode is about the unique and
dangerous SCP
2316 before we begin repeat after me and
be sure to speak clearly into the
microphone in front of you I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water a
little louder please thank you in order
to be educated about the following SCP
you must pass a vocal examination with a
cognitive resistance value of no less
than
14.5 through this video presentation you
will need to repeat the phrase to ensure
your score does not drop below the
approved threshold in the event that you
fail the test stay calm and remain where
you are until medical staff can retrieve
you remember safety is a top priority
when observing Cognito hazards the
Safeway is the only way you're a cog in
a very important machine and we wouldn't
want to have to terminate you now would
we one more time please I do not
recognize the Bodies In The Water very
good remember that you do not recognize
them no matter what you might think you
see your thoughts can be very unreliable
when you're around SCP
2316 according to our files on the
matter SCP 2316 refers to an anomalous
phenomenon identified in a Small Town
Lake it appears as a collection of human
bodies floating in a group on the
surface of the water the exact number of
corpses is unknown but it has been
estimated to be anywhere between 45 and
200 though the bodies belong to
individuals many researchers theorize
that the bodies in the water which you
do not recognize and you have never
recognized share a collective
Consciousness they function it would
seem with a hive mind of sorts the
bodies do not act on their own but as
one now where does the Cognito Hazard
come into play it would seem that anyone
who looks at the bodies in the water or
learns too much about SCP 2316 as a
whole begins to believe the corpses
floating in the lake are people they
recognize perhaps they remember their
faces from childhood or High School
whatever the case may be they become
convinced that the bodies in the water
are familiar and that they must approach
them no matter how familiar they might
seem however you do not recognize the
Bodies In The Water if a person attempts
to enter the lake reaching out to
whatever instances of SCP 2316 they
think they recognize more bodies will
begin to appear the more bodies appear
the more familiar faces seem to manifest
and the deeper the person will venture
into the lake eventually the person is
lost within the Sea of bodies likely
drowning beneath the surface or simply
becoming one with the hive mind until
they too are one of the corpses there
none of the individuals who wandered
into the lake in search of an old friend
or classmate have ever been recovered
there have been no attempts to search
the lake for their bodies as it is
unknown what effect SCP 2316 would have
on the team assigned to such a task
though we can guess that the outcome
would likely be extremely negative for
all involved those who do Venture into
the lake simply disappear never to be
seen again if you look too long at the
bodies in the lake perhaps their faces
would Sur alongside the rest but it's
best not to think about that after all
we do not recognize the Bodies In The
Water Foundation Personnel are not
allowed to approach SCP 2316 under any
circumstances the lake is only permitted
to be observed via dummy probes
outfitted with video and audio recording
equipment no one is permitted to observe
any footage or audio files collected
unless they pass through a screening for
resilience to Cognito hazardous
anomalies the lake that holds SCP 2316
has been fenced off and is patrolled by
guards with no prior knowledge of or
exposure 2 SCP
2316 anyone who attempts to approach the
lake and break through the boundaries of
its quarantine will be seized and taken
to site 33 for examination anyone who
comes within 50 m of the lake is
considered lost and presumed dead repeat
after me slowly and clearly into the
microphone I do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water good I almost believe you
let's continue only one Foundation
officer that entered the lake containing
SCP 2316 was ever stopped before they
could be lost their name has been
stricken from any official records and
you do not need to know it their
identity does not matter what matters is
the interview they gave following the
incident conducted by Dr Harrison in his
office Dr Harrison asked the anonymous
officer if they they felt compelled to
enter the Water by an invisible force as
if pulled in they rejected this concept
entirely insisting that they entered the
water of their own free will they wanted
to see the bodies who appeared to them
as their friends they wanted to hear
what the bodies were saying upon
entering the water they saw the faces of
their friends other faces were
unfamiliar but became more familiar the
longer the officer stared at their
features these were faces they had known
their entire life but something about
them was just a little bit wrong it was
like the face of someone in a dream
where you can tell they are someone you
know and you can even identify who it is
supposed to be but something about them
does not quite look right your mind
could not perfectly put their face
together from memory even though the
feeling of familiarity Remains the faces
in the water peering up through the
darkness below were like those dream
addled Memories the faces in the water
did not open their mouths but some
somehow they spoke to the officer just
the same they spoke of who they were and
asked for help they asked to be seen to
be touched they spoke of the foundation
accusing us of covering up their deaths
and keeping the world from remembering
what happened to them at this point in
the interview the subject became
agitated yelling at Dr Harrison and
refusing to be quiet guards intervened
holding the subject still as they fought
yelling at Dr Harrison repeating over
and over that they could hear the body
speaking to them every single one the
interview ended when the guards removed
the subject from the room taking them to
the amnestics department to have all
memory of the Bodies In The Water erase
from their mind then they were forgotten
once more I do not recognize the Bodies
In The Water did you repeat it good we
do not recognize the Bodies In The Water
we can't the motivations of scp2 316 if
it has any at all are largely unclear
there are those on the research staff
that theorize the hive mind or
Collective consciousness of the bodies
is not malevolent in nature it is they
believe simply trying to make sure that
a tragedy that occurred in that lake is
remembered perhaps many lives were lost
to an anomalous force in that Lake and
the impact of that massive tragedy left
behind an impression on the location
this impression manifests in the form of
bodies spontaneously appearing in an
impossibly well preserved condition the
Cognito Hazard of SCP 2316 is not
intended to kill anyone or take them but
rather to force strangers to remember
the people who lost their lives to the
lake this sense of familiarity whether
it is false or not ensures that the dead
will not be forgotten or left alone
after all no one deserves to be left
alone though there have been lives lost
to the Cognito Hazard according to the
foundation it is understandable why the
bodies would want to be recognized to
have someone somewhere know who they
were to have someone remember their
names Jeremiah finman Arthur Scott
Denise
Clark where was I oh yes repeat after me
once again I do not recognize the bodies
in the water I do not recognize them I
do
not but that's a lie isn't it I do
recognize them how could I not I know
them they're my friends do you recognize
them look at their faces don't fight the
memories look into their eyes the class
of 1975 they were supposed to graduate
that fall they were just kids group of
innocent kids lost to the dark and deep
what happened to them I can't quite
remember but I know that it mattered
enough for the foundation to keep the
secret and I know that somehow I
survived but I shouldn't have I should
be there with them I should be there
there isn't much time I can hear the
guards coming to retrieve me their
footsteps thundering down the hall I
failed the test and the alarm has gone
off they think I'm lost but I'm not I've
never been less lost in my entire life
I've finally woken up to the truth I
remember I have to go I have to return
to the lake fall of 1975 they went for a
swim my friends they're calling to me I
can hear them so clearly even from so
far away their CRI is for help ringing
in my ears their voices curling around
me pulling me to the edge of the water
the guards will come for you too they'll
know you've seen this they'll call you
compromis they'll say I succumb to the
effects of the Cognito Hazard they'll
say you did too you'll fail their little
tests and they'll say that makes you
weak and broken but you cannot listen
they're lying it's not a hazard it's a
scream for help they're screaming and
the foundation keeps covering it up they
won't let us find them and they won't
tell us why I have to go back so we can
be together again there are signs posted
all around the lake danger drowning
Hazard those are a trick it's to keep me
out to to keep the truth from me the
barb wire fenes around it it's just
another trick I'll climb over it rung
after rung I don't care if the barbs
tear my clothes or pierce my skin it's
worth it for the truth for the memory
and once I've climbed to the top I'll be
able to see there through the fog I can
see their faces their lips parted in a
constant cry their eyes wide looking for
me my friends my family every face
unlocking a memory long buried I know
them all and I must go further I can't
turn back now I have to wade into the
water Let its chills soak into my
clothes down to my bones one step and
another deeper and deeper the water
lapping at my ankles my knees my thighs
the deeper I go the more sure I will be
that this is where I belong the water
will engulf my chest my neck until my
feet no longer touch the ground I will
be lost in it water flooding into my
mouth pouring into every opening I will
let my body sink down down down to the
bottom where they've been all this time
nestled in the dirt and the dust they've
been so patient but it's finally time
they're ready to be remembered to be
seen to be found they're waiting for me
and they're waiting for you too can you
hear them I'm going now you have to find
me you have to follow me don't let the
guards stop you don't let them wipe it
all away from your mind fight break free
and find the lake hop the fence make
your way into the water you can't leave
me there to fade away floating in the
cold with the rest can you hear us we're
waiting you edge the poolside chlorine
stench air filling your nose the sound
of splashing and lifeguards whistling
bouncing off the indoor pool facility
walls the water ripples family and
friends egging you to cannonball in the
pool almost beckoning you to jump with
its suggestive waves yet there remains
an underlying fear one that brings your
hands to your face and causes your teeth
to chatter even as the pool clear as
glass with chlorine hides no secrets a
monster some teeth nashing Megalodon
ascending from the depths of Extinction
Leviathan curling its Barbed tail to
strike its prey at any moment or even
some vast unknowable Force ancient as
Earth hardly comprehensible to human
Minds waiting dreaming to breach the
surface no matter what form this
gargantuan invisible monster takes you
know one thing once you jump in you will
not return to shore you take a moment
recompose yourself and laugh off the
fear maybe a product of too much
research on the bloop that deep ocean
sound continuing to confound scientists
as to its cause or maybe too much
binging infographics videos on sea
monsters Krakens and Lochness monsters
mysterious globsters cast onto Shores
throughout America whatever the origin
the thought seems ridiculous to you now
and your fears regarding invisible
sharks stalking the pool perimeter
Escape your mind as you hurl yourself
into the water sccp 1128 in the vast
Archives of a hidden site stuffed into a
drawer amongst uncountable Horrors like
it the SCP Foundation holds a
description of a vast unfathomable
horror that'll make you more suspicious
the next time you pass a pool lake or
even a bathtub or puddle of water SCP
1128 is a gigantic aquatic monster
lurking in waters unknown and that's all
the foundation will let anyone not
assigned to testing know about it while
the foundation has never shed away from
those Moby Dicks of the deep including
the several thousand kilm long arthropod
SCP 169 and has even utilized such
predators in the past for their own
benefit like the lengthy Beast SCP 3000
SCP 1128 poses a unique challenge anyone
who knows of its description Beyond
surface level details will fall under
the anomaly's effect the representation
you seen now is merely an artist's
interpretation of the basic prompt the
found Foundation of course had to
discover the monster's effects in the
first place the chain of communication
becomes foggy but a tip from an unknown
source alerted the foundation to the
monster's existence and details
regarding its manifestation one man who
had stumbled upon the entity's full
description started developing acute
thalassophobia the fear of large bodies
of water not Bodies In The Water mind
you the man refused to relax on the
beach or fly overseas claiming he could
see the Monster's dark silhouette
lurking underwater ever scouting for him
this eventually extended to even closed
bodies of water like lakes ponds and
pools still insisting that the creature
swam under the surface trailing him
wherever he went his friends dismissed
him as crazy and he too believed he had
fallen under some hysteria he decided to
take a nice warm bath to soothe his mind
and ease his troubles he turned on the
faucet and let the tub fill up he put on
his best bathing suit ready to calm his
anxiety once and for all this had been
plaguing his mind for far too long and
he was ready to rid all the negativity
surrounding this phobia basically he was
sick and tired of being sick and tired
over the idea of it all he mustered up
the courage and with the anticipation to
just simply relax he took his first
confident step into the tub he paused
for a moment and breathed a sigh of
relief he picked up his other foot and
stepped fully into the bath Splash he
fell straight down right through the tub
waves and Bubbles blocked his vision his
arms flailed as he sunk deeper into an
abyss of water and fear this wasn't
supposed to happen he thought several
moments later while still in a full-on
panic the buoyancy of his body began to
slow his sinking the bubbles from his
underwater screams Rose above him he
began to follow their Direction
scrambling back up to where he'd come
just as he made it it back to the
surface of the tub water choking and
hyperventilating in Terror he swore he
could see a distant creature the very
same that stalked him through oceans and
pools staring at him shaking he hoisted
himself out of the water and ran out of
the house hysterical he ran through the
surrounding neighborhood desperately
searching for someone he could relay his
experience to Blinded By fear he
neglected to spot a puddle in the middle
of the road he ran on he raised his foot
arched forward and landed straight into
the seemingly shallow water splash again
he found himself completely submerged
and drowning after a minute he did
emerge from the puddle but not in one
piece knowledgeable of this incident the
foundation set about expunging any
traces of the monster's description from
the world physical and digital the
description had low distribution
according to the results of foundation
web crawlers but this hardly stopped the
foundation's Endeavor with Forum posts
deleted individuals located and
amnestied and catalogs trolled to ensure
the description did not proliferate the
foundation engaged in what it does best
questionably ethical experiments first
they had an anonymous d-class uninformed
of the creature's effect read the
description of the Beast while the
pamphlet they gave him confused him
somewhat he didn't feel particularly
frightened by The Entity and he
confusedly put on the diving suit the
foundation testers provided him as they
connected him to a cable and told him to
enter a bathtub the d-class did as they
instructed him the d-class expressed
initial confusion at the tub's depth
remarking that it looks so tiny from the
outside as the declass continued to
descend he analyzed his surroundings
realizing the nautical reality that
enveloped him he asked how an ocean got
stuffed into a bathtub but the test
organizer had no room for miscellaneous
talk he continued to descend until until
he hit the Sandy Bottom seaweed covering
the ocean floor the declass looked
around tropical fish swam in schools
Coral covered the seabed and to his
right dropped an immense Cliff a sheer
Edge the test organizer advised the
declass to approach the cliff and he
begrudgingly complied as he struggled in
his diving suit he fell back and scream
SC SCP 1128 The Aquatic horror swam
distantly gracefully even and paid no
attention to the d-class so fixated upon
it he realized that the creature matched
the one he read on the pamphlet and
almost complained about this when he saw
a blue whale swimming alongside SCP 1128
compared to the monster the whale looked
like a guppy the whale glided in front
of SCP 1128 Jaws the monster remained
tranquil stared at its prey and bit the
whale in two with one cha its teeth
glistened in the water the test operator
requested the d-class to pull back and
as the cable began to draw him toward
where he came d-class stared at the
creature swallowing the chunks of whale
hole the DCL class's eyes remained
fixated on the creature partially in
Fright partially in awe he wondered how
ocean trollers hadn't discovered such a
giant Beast yet with the world
effectively under 100% surveillance
something the d-class knew far too well
as a convict yet the d-class recognized
and if not comprehended ended partially
understood the ocean's vastness and
mystery the dark depths reveal no
inkling as to their contents and a
creature like a giant squid or the cican
can remain in hiding for centuries if
not Millennia it held him in wondrous
thought to consider the vastness of the
depths when SCP 1128 stopped and stared
at the declass this feeling of Wonder
was quickly replaced with fear as the
creature approached approach the d-class
pleaded with the test operators for help
as the test operators accelerated the
rate of the cable returning the d-class
took short shallow breaths filling his
body with dangerous nitrogen as he
ascended further impairing his judgment
he had devolved into gibberish and
screaming when face to face the monster
consumed its prey the cable went slack
and the test operator pulled up only a
broken wire snap the water turning a
cloudy red the test operator knew that
the unprotected to d-class had no chance
at survival against the monster but he
could potentially arm and shield them he
had another similarly ignorant d-class
once again dress in a scuba suit and
enter the tongue however the test
operator placed the d-class within a
shark cage all out of the movie Jaws and
lowered the cage in with another cable
and winch system while Unsure how this
would Faire with that SCP 1128 the test
operator remained hopeful that the
d-class could survive and recount his
story un fortunately as the cage lowered
into the tub the test operator received
no response from the d-class until the
line spontaneously tightened snapped and
loosened hoping to find the DCL class's
Remains the test operator only found
shredded pieces of metal torn and
twisted like taffy the test operator
decided that he could utilize the
foundation's Arsenal to his advantage
and used an anomalously toughened shark
cage in his testing perhaps using an
anomaly like the Clockwork machine SC
SCP 914 he gained approval from his
high-ups to undergo this procedure and
after some testing behind a shining
strong as titanium shark cage which he
placed another d-class within hoping for
a success with the monster however
proved unsatisfactory as the same thing
happened as the previous test only
without any sort of metallic remains
while bitter that the monster had won
again he wondered where the cage had
landed meanwhile Foundation forces
labored tirelessly to find SCP 11 28's
location hoping to avoid any civilian
contact with the creature luckily a GPS
signal established itself upon the most
recent DCL classes test with a tracking
device on the d-class signifying the
monster's General location the
foundation had redacted the location of
the monster perhaps in a vain attempt to
hide a very near threat from potential
readers the foundation set up a team of
only the most talented boers in its
forces mobile Containment Force Kappa 12
sea devils upon arriving at the location
the sea Devils discovered the previously
enhanced shark cage completely undamaged
however closer inspection revealed
traces of human DNA on the bars though
the foundation could not confirm whether
the DNA belonged to the previously sent
declass the test operator while glad his
shark cage survived the monster's attack
still found himself dissatisfied with
the overall results of the test he knew
he needed to quell this creature's
impact before a large population viewed
it or knew of it the horrible Beast had
evaded all attempts at peaceful
interaction perhaps with a Madness not
unlike Captain Ahab yearning for the
death of his white whale the test
operator armed a d-class with a
specialized weapon designed to deal with
aquatic threats promptly this weapon
potentially another of the foundation's
precious Arsenal could potentially harm
if not kill the creature while he knew
the foundation's mission statement
forbade unnecessary destruction the test
operator felt it may turn necessary if
matters turn any worse thus he sent his
armed declass through the tub once more
ready to engage the beast in combat the
attempt as one may expect did not last
long the d-class upon spotting the
creature aimed his weapon at the monster
and attacked it but rather than drive
the creature away it only turned
intently upon the d-class as if it
desired a fight the d-class barely
managed to scrape SCP 1128 before the
creature devoured the d-class leaving
the test operator once again
empty-handed defeated and without any
more resources to deal with the Beast
the test operator ceased his attempts at
vesting the creature and followed the
foundation's more cautious approach
expunging any publicly found
descriptions of SCP 1128 as needed and
diverting any vessels away from the
anomaly's exclusion Zone as maintained
by the Sea Devils well the creature had
proven treacherous in unexpected
situations prior engulfing the man who
first heard the creature's description
in a rain puddle researchers could
hardly expect what would transpire a
d-class Afflicted with the monster's
effect and observed for testing avoided
all bodies of water as required
eventually however the d-class needed to
interact with some kind of water
drinking water in a choice between a
little water exposure or certain death
the d-class felt inclined to choose the
former he filled his cup with water and
for fun placed his finger into the cup
dropping it into into the water SCP 1128
unseen from the outside violently pulled
the declass through the cup into its
watery domain the d-class had not a
chance to scream this alarmed
containment staff now cognizant that
even the tiniest specks of water could
transport an Afflicted person into SCP
1128 ocean territory this proved
particularly strenuous when a new report
of a potential SCP 11128 manifestation
arose an old woman isolated with cats
and knitting supplies found an article
online with a description of the monster
frightened and disgusted by what she
read she closed the article and
continued on with her monotonous life
such a life would take a turn for the
worst however when she too developed
that all encompassing water-based fear
her apartment overlooked an outdoor pool
and one day looking outside she swore
she could see that same dark silhouette
as the man did lurking in the water
among kids and parents playing she
swiftly closed the window curtains and
taped the seam shut allowing no light to
peek through eventually this paranoia
affected her hygiene neglecting showers
and baths for fear of the creature's
wrath she swore she could see the
silhouette in any individual droplet of
water her skin began to flake as she
avoided water as much as humanly
possible cracks developing on her arms
legs and face inflaming into rashes and
itches her scratching further increased
the flaking she even eliminated water
from her diet sealing the faucets with
duct tape and consuming exclusively
orange juice she threw out her cat's
water bowls dehydrating them they
pleaded with her as she continued to
devolve avoiding any contact with the
outside world even as it attempted to
contact her eventually a concerned
neighbor contacted the local police
concerning the situation and the case
caught the foundation's radar
recognizing the symptoms of a potential
SC CP 1128 infection a mobile task force
disguised themselves as civilians to
enter the apartment building and
potentially interfere with the woman's
condition they entered the complex
climbing up the stairs with barraging
equipment for forced entry as would
prove necessary to use to enter the
woman's apartment she had nailed the
door shut with wood and sealed the
cracks along the sides with plaster in
an attempt to keep out any water vapor
she had similarly blocked the window
with wood planks a horrid miasma of dead
skin and Citrus filled the apartment the
old woman soaking it in ever avoiding
the dreaded monster the foundation task
force attempted peaceful entry knocking
on the door and asking if anyone lived
in the apartment the woman couldn't
speak if she wanted to her throat had
dried to near silence save a croak
suddenly the task force and the woman
heard a rumbling noise outside thunder
rain the woman panicked and yelled don't
come in here in a froggy voice the task
force eventually decided they needed to
use their equipment and entered via
barrage the door collapsed and an
immediate densed air clogged the task
Force's sight blinding and choking them
the woman shrieked and backed against
the window inadvertently the task force
insisted they were here to help the
woman but she simply heaved heavily
saying something unintelligible in that
dry cracking voice the rain began
pounding on the window patter patter
patter as the task force attempted to
gain hold of the woman she resisted
their movements moving around the room
while the task force intentionally
avoided violent confrontation the rain
grew in its intensity as the woman
continued running around her apartment
tripping over her starved cats
eventually she fell back onto the window
at which the boards blocking it fell
onto the floor exposing the pouring rain
fully she screamed as she saw the
silhouette of the monster staring at her
in every individual raindrop one drop
landed on her skin and she violently
vanished pulled into a minuscule Speck
of water the task force collaps from
exhaustion perhaps dreading their
inevitable amnestic treatment following
exposure with an SCP 1128 afflect yet
they couldn't help but wonder what the
old woman saw in a single Speck of water
that could cause that degree of fear and
paranoia the kind of fear only caused by
entire oceans condensed into a single
droplet besides the monster what else
did she see in those multitude of
droplets the fish that populated the sea
the whale carcasses left behind by SCP
1128 the sea Devils viewed from below
Drifting On The Water unsuspecting just
as one may view a grain of sand and see
the Sahara she too saw that raindrop and
viewed an ocean entire along with
whatever malevolent creatures inhabit it
one may have more Sympathy for the child
reluctant to jump into the pool water
knowing not necessarily that something
inhabits that body of water but that the
body belongs to a cycle much larger than
itself larger than any sea or Ocean and
the only thing that can Traverse that
cycle is a monster a creature like SCP
1128 the task force went back to their
local site to report what happened
during the incident like so many
incidents the foundation deals with the
sum total of those that risk their lives
for the greater good is a couple memory
erasing syringes and another update to
documentation a description of SCP 1128
remains in the stuffy Locker lurking in
weight among other horrifying stories in
the SCP databases Sea Of Terror just
like that test operator that attempted
to best the monster could the
foundation's attempts ever surmount the
possibility of another person being
Afflicted could they conquer the sea in
a member of that task Force's dreams
they perceive a dark blue ocean and the
distant black shadow that resides within
and from this ocean they can view the
bathtubs sinks pools puddles cups of
water and Rain droplets of the world
seen from below although they know not
what SCP 1128 looks like they too
experience the fear it summons among
those that do the paranoia the fear
although it may not manifest directly in
people's lives it can always be observed
stalking waiting lurking under a murky
surface watching with hidden
eyes imagine this you're a researcher
with an interest in and an aptitude for
marine biology over the years your work
has taken you far and wild to the
furthest corners of the Earth's oceans
you've observed countless species of sea
life from fish and Crustaceans to whales
and sharks predators and prey alike
during one of your travels you find
yourself off the coast of South Africa
monitoring the local population of sea
creatures looking out across the water
you see a large dark shape moving below
the surface there is a shadow streaking
its way towards Your Vessel Dark As
night speeding Like a Torpedo you rush
across the deck leaning over the port
side as the shape swims beneath your
bout you're certain you you know what it
was after all your years studying the
world beneath the waves you know a whale
shark when you see one the largest known
species of fish still in existence the
whale shark is a filter feeder
consisting on a diet of Plankton and
other tiny aquatic organisms a whale
shark poses absolutely no threat to
humans or rather any whale shark other
than this one would impose a threat but
how could you know that scanning the
water you strain your eyes trying to
spot what you assumed was an or ordinary
whale shark swimming below but there is
nothing no sign of it anywhere sighing
you think you might have missed your
chance to see one in the wild perhaps it
changed Direction instead of swimming
under the boat you tell yourself the
ship turns and starts making its way
back towards the small Harbor leaving
you blissfully unaware that there's an
extra passenger on board as you
disembark you notice something on the
side of the boat emblazened on the hole
is a motif of a familiar shape a whale
shark depicted entirely in painted dots
you stare at it for a moment intrigued
by the pattern it reminds you of a piece
you once saw an Aboriginal Australian
style of dot art you're a little taken
aback by The Coincidence having briefly
spotted a whale shark while out at Sea
earlier blissfully unaware that this
painting marks your first encounter with
SCP
1449 known more colloquially as the
dream time whale shark in fact you're so
amused by seeing the whale shark earlier
only to find one painted here on the
boat that it distracts you you don't
realize that the whale shark painting
hadn't been on the side of the boat when
you'd shipped out instead you pay the
crew and thank the captain for letting
you hire The Vessel for your research
and then head off by the time you make
it back to the nearby town and settle
down in after a long day on the water
the dotted painting of the whale shark
has already slipped from your
mind but as you begin drifting off and
everything goes dark you're about to
find out that your encounter with the
Dreamtime whale shark is only just
beginning you've never been a heavy
sleeper and rarely remember your dreams
any that you might have seem to pass out
of your head the moment you wake up or
are too faint for you to acknowledge
while you're sleeping but tonight is
different tonight you're dreaming
vividly in this dream water surrounds
you like it has your whole career but
this time you're underneath the surface
a drift in an empty the ocean nothing
around you but endless blank sea you
feel something in your hand something
smooth and moving gently like organic
matter something alive you find yourself
gripping the tail of a whale shark and
somehow as is often the way with dreams
you know that this is the same whale
shark from earlier that
day the one that swam up to your boat
and ended up sticking on the side of it
as a DOT art painting SCP 1449 has this
latent abil
while it normally appears as a flat
two-dimensional piece of Aboriginal
Australian dot art the dream time whale
shark can shift whenever it is
underwater it still appears as a
collection of painted dots in this
unmistakable shape of a whale shark but
in an aquatic environment it becomes
three-dimensional and that's what you'd
seen swimming towards the boat not just
a whale shark but SCP
1449 within your dream you release the
Dreamtime whale shark's tail and begin
to float
upwards breaking the surface of the
water you breathe lungfuls of fresh air
the first thing you see is land and it's
close by close enough for you to swim to
shore paddling through the water you
reach an island one in a chain of small
land masses tiny continents in a shallow
unfamiliar ocean you look back to the
water but can find no sign of SCP 1449
the Dreamtime whale shark has brought
you here and left you on this island but
you can only speculate as to why there
must be a reason you insist to yourself
the Dreamscape around you it would seem
is either the creation of SCP 1449 or at
the very least a side effect of falling
asleep close by to where you saw the
Dreamtime whale shark and its painted
form whatever this place is there must
be some way to uncover an answer it
stands for reason you think that if you
can understand what's going on then
perhaps therein lies the key to escaping
this dream and when waking up back in
reality the small island you find
yourself on and the others nearby are
inhabited by strange life forms as you
walk across the shore sand clinging to
your wet feet you approach what you
thought at a distance to be a group of
other people instead you see a group of
peculiar beings they are not quite human
but they are definitely close the closer
you walk you notice these strange
humanoid shapes huddle tighter together
their backs to you when you try to call
out to them asking where you are or how
you might return to reality they bustle
away the wind carries the sound of their
chatter towards you and you're certain
you hear them call you another one just
another traveler from afar what you
don't realize lost in this dream
environment is that there are others
like it pocket worlds like this one
similar but different currently being
experienced by any others asleep near
SCP
1449 as you Ponder what to do on the
beach the captain of the boat you hired
is on a different version of the same
island watching a herd of multiple 2,000
kilo platypi being shephered by six
tattooed 3M tall humanoid figures
meanwhile his first m is in another
version of this dream world learning how
to hunt under the tutelage of a man
called gray the rabbit Hunter each
version of SCP 1449 Dreamscape have
separate continuities to each other they
are differing copies of the same chain
of islands with the same inhabitants but
each visited by a different traveler
from afar in their sleep much like a
lucid dream visitors to the Dreamtime
whale sharks worlds can interact with
them shaping and altering events in the
continuity they find themselves in
deciding to leave the beach you El to
make your way towards Higher Ground to
try to get a wider scope of your
surroundings fortunately there is a
towering mountainous shape nearby
standing like dark serrated teeth
against the clear Horizon you begin your
dangerous track ascending your way up
these dead Jagged Hills you're still
unclear on how you got here or how to
escape but you will yourself to keep
climbing knowing there must be some way
to wake up from this bizarre dream
finally reaching level ground you take a
moment to catch your breath collecting
your thoughts before advancing any
further you turn gazing out over the
landscape spreading out below and all
around you the island is small enough
you can see the shore where you arrive
and the ocean flanking this land mass on
all sides in this short moment you
appreciate the beauty of this bizarre
Dream World for the first time the trees
Sway in the gentle breeze moving like
the calm rolling of waves in the water
Beyond both glistening with the warm
light of the sun well it is still true
that you have no idea how or why SCP
1449 brought you here or how to leave
you think to yourself that at least this
dream environment isn't a hostile way
one not that you'd want to be stranded
there forever but there are certainly
far more unforgiving places one can
dream about a grim thought suddenly
Dawns on you how long have you been here
does time pass differently in this world
to the one you're still asleep in a
sound shakes your thoughts back to your
current here and now it was a voice
you're sure of it a voice calling out
but not to you traversing the dead
Jagged Hills you see a figure a person
from The Real World like you not one of
the local humanoids they don't see you
they're calling out to someone in a
ramshackle Hut cobbled together from
pieces of wood and other scraps on the
arm of the figure's dark military-like
uniform is a symbol and you can just
make out three distinct letters s
c a wooden plank that functioned as the
door creaked open revealing a second
figure the man looks disheveled his worn
clothing patched with scraps of leather
and shark skin making him looked as
cobbled together as his Mak shift Hut
like he was an extension of the small
structure he watch as the man talks to
the agent overhearing his words don't
say anything if you say anything I lose
my mind you could say anything and
something horrible happens the strange
man warns talking too quickly for the
foundation agent to reply you're a
dreamer like me my name is Nikolai I am
the ship Seer of the dunum and the
Brotherhood
of the man Nikolai he called himself
seemed distressed tripping over his
words disagreeing with himself until he
starts trailing off into swearing
obscenity I'm not Nikolai he shouts I am
aent agent John before stumbling and
cursing again I'm sorry I can't can't
keep the memory straight being this
Lucid for this long hurts the dreaming
fills in all the gaps things have always
been even as they are brought into being
I've been on this Cliff since the
beginning of time just like how this
place has always been here the dream was
torn Away by the deaths of gods Before
Time began but I watched it happen 5
years ago are you
following I can barely tell the dream
and reality apart anymore my world has
always been the way it is and we made it
like that we hurt the dreaming the shark
that's how we see it we hurt it killed
it in our world and the dream time
poured out like it spilled blood and we
made this big scar here and and things
are wrong fish walk and ghosts haunt the
stones and women give birth to plastic
children and the leech Fields stretch
out forever in the Seas of human blood
and the center eats cocaine and caviar
out of pandas skull BS on the crushed
backs of opal mares in acres of broken
glass and it has always been like this
don't don't do it don't do it again
you're already racing back down to the
dead Jagged Hills the side of the
deranged Nikolai burned into your mind a
man reduced to a babbling lunatic Cast
Away and left alone in this strange
dream skate that SCP 1449 brought you to
but Nikolai is more than that more than
just someone driven mad by his isolation
he is a grim prophecy of what will
become of you unless you can find a way
to leave the Dreamtime will shark swirl
already back on the beach you drop down
kneeling in the wet sand as the tide
washes is over your knees the how or why
of SCP 1449 bringing you into this dream
isn't important all that matters to you
is avoiding ending up like Nikolai
whatever it takes you know one thing
above all else you need to wake up but
whether you actually ever will is
another question entirely the year is
1985 16th of February a pair of
researchers aboard a model sm03 deep sea
submersible are descending into the
depths of the Atlantic Ocean hours ago
they were somewhere just off the coast
of France surrounded by Blue Sky the
smell of the Sea and the warm embrace of
the Sun but now only cold Darkness
surrounds them the depth of the ocean so
vast and overwhelming even light could
not Escape its grasp the Twan team are
members of MTF gamma 6 also known as the
Deep feeders a special task force that
specialized in the investigation and
tracking of deep sea or Oceanic
anomalies their mission to locate and
investigate the wreckage of a World War
II German warship known as the bismar
thought by the general public to have
gone down in the naval battle with the
British in
1941 but the story the public doesn't
know is the real reason the pair of
foundation members were tasked with
locating the ship's wreckage site
unfortunately for these researchers
today would be remembered for something
far worse than they had anticipated
radio Transmissions recorded by the
gamma 6 Duo detailed the events that
took place upon finding the bismar
designated SCP
4217 the bismar lay at the bottom of the
ocean partially submerged in the sea
floor but to the astonishment of
researchers it appeared to be perfectly
intact with no signs of damage from its
previous Naval engagements gamma 6
member Charles Miller comments even
after the better part of 5 decades
this ship is still in pristine condition
there is no water damage anywhere that I
can see even stranger no ocean sediment
has accumulated on the hole of the ship
whatsoever prompted to investigate
closer agent Victor Miller begins
operation of the crew model rv1 Marine
probe an unmanned robotic exploratory
drone that allows the researchers to
explore the interior of the ship's
wreckage what they found unnerved them
or better said what they didn't find
just as the outside of the vessel
appeared free of any corrosion or wear
the interior of the ship was just as
Immaculate the hallways were clean the
walls adorned freshly painted signs in
still legible German even the Nazi
symbols painted onto command centers
still held no sign of disintegration it
was as if the ship had just come off the
assembly line but strangest of all was
the lack of skeletal remains at the time
it was sunk the original crew Pro the
bismar boasted a minimum of 2,000 men
where were the bodies continuing the
mission the researchers piloted their
unmanned drone down the Eerie winding
corridors along several of the inner
corridors of the submerged wreckage of
SCP
4217 the crew find large thick walls of
what appear to be made out of a
rubberlike substance soon they find that
the large vein-like growths extend
throughout the interior of the ship like
tendrils growing in size the closer the
exploratory drone gets to the center of
the vessel all the while a slight hum
sound is picked up by the Craft's sonar
equipment echoing from the center of the
ship a rhythmic pulsing the crew decide
they need to take a sample of the
rubber-like substance back to Foundation
headquarters for testing this would be a
mistake upon cutting into the thick
tentacle like growths the researchers
noticed something that fills their
stomachs with Dread whatever substance
they had cut into was now bleeding the
team Hears A Distant Rumble growing
steadily louder suddenly the ship begins
to move shuffling sand and debris strew
along the seaf Flor clouding the
visibility of the ship terrified the
pair hurried to try and disconnect the
cable attaching the probe to their
submersible and Evacuate the site but
it's too late a booming thud shakes the
underwater craft as a large Shadow
covers the glass window of the
submersible alarm systems go off as
cracks start to appear in the glass
surface the PA attempt to Pilot The
Vessel up towards the surface surface
but they are halted by a strong force
pulling them downward just as the cracks
start to spread across the surface of
the glass A giant shadow looms over the
submersible what is that screams and the
sound of shattering glass can be heard
on the recording as the submersible
implodes from the pressure of the watery
depths since that unfortunate incident
Foundation members have recorded
multiple occurrences of SCP 4217
attacking civilian cargo ships in the
Atlantic particularly off the coast of
the United Kingdom and as far north as
the Greenland sea given its ker
containment classification containment
of SCP 4217 consists of constant
monitoring by Foundation Naval forces
with the cooperation of the British
royal Navy in episodes of aggression or
an agitated or hostile State Naval
forces are instructed to forcibly subdue
SCP 427 through Naval engagement once
enough damage is sustained SCP 4217
enters a passive State and res submerges
SCP 4217 is divided into two parts SCP
4217 daa is the bismar itself a Nazi era
warship outfitted with an array of eight
main guns 44 secondary armaments and
dozens of units of anti-aircraft
Weaponry SCP 4217 DB refers to the
anomalous seapod organism embedded
inside the hull of the ship SCP 4217 has
two large rectangular pupils inside of
octopod eyes that protrude from the base
of the ship as well as 12 100 to 200 M
long tendril-like muscular appendages
that extend outward from an opening in
the stern of the vessel SCP 4217 is
deemed to be classification risk class
dangerous with reports of it emitting a
mild psionic field within a 20 km radius
confusing anything within range and
increasing the likelihood of Friendly
Fire among enemy combat PL SC SCP 4217
daa's Hull seems to have the ability of
inorganic regeneration as damage
incurred from enemy vessels seems to
immaculately repair over time
researchers have observed what appears
to be runes or cryptic markings on the
side of SCP 4217 daa's Hall It is
believed these symbols were part of the
original ship's design to bolster the
vessel's defense Integrity though not
immediately visible when the vessel is
taking fire the symbols appear to Glow
in proportion to the amount of damage
being mitigated among its offensive
capabilities apart from the standard
armaments of a World War II era warship
SCP 421 17-a also has specialized
Munitions of an unidentifiable gas
compound that is reported to have
mutagenic properties individuals that
have been exposed to the gas compound
undergo rapid spontaneous metamorphosis
at a molecular level growing an array of
evolutionary attributes which include
the accumulation of reptile likee SC
scales or Aven feathers in place of skin
the increase or decrease of the number
of Limbs digits or even ocular olfactory
or auditory organs and in one reported
case an event where multiple members of
One crew were fused at a subatomic level
into one functioning organism the more
study into this particular incident is
needed SCP 4217 also has the ability of
subsurface Oceanic mobility and can
submerge itself when not in combat with
enemy vessels
underwater propulsion appears to be
generated by the ejection of water from
SCP 4217 DB's body cavity and reaches a
top speed of approximately 30 knots SCP
4217 undergoes cycles of passive
behavior that is periodically
interrupted by moments of hostility
towards civilian craft particularly
resurfacing and going after
transatlantic cargo vessels it is belied
this is analogous to the history and
original Mission of the bismar operation
ryanbang during World War II the German
luwa was besieging London in a series of
nightly Air Raids that would be
colloquially known as The Blitz it was
the Grand intention of the third right
to cut off supplies to the British to
limit their resistance to the Nazi war
machine however what pestered the Nazis
most and hindered this effort was the
consistent American Support provided by
the US government in the form of food
and supplies delivered to the British
via Atlantic trade routes by cargo ship
the German bismar and her sister ship
the tarpits were created for the very
goal of stopping these transports of
cargo to the United Kingdom as well as
sinking as many Allied vessels as
possible the year is 1937 in a top
secret effort to make preparations for
an approaching War Adolf Hitler turns to
his most trusted expert on the
supernatural Chief SS officer Hinrich
himler among other projects himler
ordered the anner obscura cor a German
organization tasked with the procurement
and investigation of other worldly or
otherwise unexplainable phenomenon to
begin the creation of two ships the
bismar and the turits the former named
after the Iron Chancellor ovon bismar
who in 1890 unified the German people
these vessels were to be created using
recently uncovered technological
Oddities the obscur cor had found in
their studies of the occult sources of
information about the exact creation of
SCP 4217 are highly expunged from the
record but bits and pieces did survive
among what little the foundation was
able to El and in the records of the
USSR after their occupation of Eastern
Germany following the fall of the Nazi
regime during the second world war the
earliest mention of SCP 427's conception
dates back to early 1937 when a top
secret shipment of unknown materials
labeled component of thical constructs
is intercepted by a foundation agent
working under cover in a German shipment
Center outside of Hamburg the foundation
anent Marcus stob is instructed to
maintain surveillance on the shipment in
1939 upon near completion of the soon
Tobe christened bismar a second shipment
labeled with the Insignia of the obscura
cor is intercepted by the foundation
agent only this shipment appears unlike
any other reports of the massive
shipping container holding Machinery
capable of Aquatic Life Support indicate
organic living cargo though the
foundation agent was unable to identify
the exact nature of the contents of the
shipment straw reported hearing sounds
emanating from the cargo hold sounds
similar to that of a heartbeat just a
year later the bismar is seen making its
first Naval trial run when it
experiences a massive electrical
discharge just offshore shutting the
vessel down momentarily until power was
restored shortly after reports show
luminescent symbols briefly visible on
the hull of the ship theological symbols
for the Layman are symbols that embodied
the study of Miracles because of this it
was apparent to the foundation that some
occult anomaly was responsible for the
strange characteristics of the German
vessel and an order for termination was
reached by the 05 Council the hunt for
SCP
4217 in the Autumn of 1940 under orders
of neutralization of SCP 4217 all active
Foundation agents presiding in Germany
were ordered to converge on the side of
the bismar to stop the completion of the
vessel but when the time came for the
operation every single one of the
foundation agents vanish no records of
what happened were ever found no
clothing notes not even a trace of their
existence was left behind the mission
was deemed a failure and subsequent
attempts to neutralize SCP 4217 became
far more difficult after the bismar
received a full crew of seamen the fully
manned and well equipped SCP 4217 became
a menace to both military and civilian
Craft on the high seas of the Atlantic
at times appearing without warning
seemingly out of thin air SCP 4217
psionic field obscured it from the new
tech technological advancements in enemy
radar systems the US government had in
development the ship became a shadow on
the Atlantic a subject of ghost stories
for anyone daring to assist the British
government with the war effort
furthermore SCP 4217 did not seem to be
content with the surrender of enemy
vessels captured enemy ships were gassed
turning the men into manufactured beasts
and then sinking the enemy vessels to
the depths of the ocean even submarines
were no match on one report to
describing an attempt to elude The
Vessel by diving below the surface only
to be entangled by enormous squid-like
appendages that dragged the craft back
up to the surface before crushing it in
its grasp fearing the safety of the
public the 05 Council decided they could
not stand by and let more innocent lives
be taken they voted to supersede the
foundation's policy on absolute secrecy
to notify the British government of the
danger SCP 4217 pose to Maritime
civilians with cooperation from the
British royal Navy Foundation
Representatives joined the crew of HMS
hood and HMS Prince of Wales to track
reports of the bismar being cited off
the coast of Scandinavia in what history
books would come to know as the Battle
of Denmark Straight HMS hood and HMS
Prince of Wales engaged SCP 4217 and a
secondary German warship known as the
prin Yen confused by the ship's psionic
field the British naval ships
experienced trouble identifying the
bismar and engage in Friendly Fire
before being able to regain control of
their armaments concentrating all volley
of fire on SCP
4217 the attack proves futile as after
the Embers and smoke of Munitions fire
wear off the sides of the bismar hull
appear to vibrate with glowing energy
mangled metal begins to straighten back
into perfect frame breaches and armor
begin to heal before the soldiers very
eyes and all that is left as evidence
the ship had ever taken fire is a cloud
of steam emanating from the hull of SCP
42 17 the water surrounding the vessel
begin to boil as underwater tentacles
Lurch out and capture the HMS Hood
dragging her majesty ship forward the
men aboard frantically try to regain
control but seconds later are met with
another crisis a salvo of artillery
shells fired from SCP 427's guns hit the
ship severing lines and damaging rail
guns as a mutagenic gas compound starts
to spread among the Royal seamen in mere
minutes the majority of the crew are
engulfed in toxic fumes and experience
vomiting and convulsions their bodies
undergoing rapid involuntary mutagenesis
including the growth of Limbs the
development of fur feathers and scales
in one report it was said that multiple
victims even fused together to create
one single horrifying entity those
exposed to the gases compound were
designated SCP 421
17-1 the captain of the HMS Hood
barricades himself inside the helm but
the resulting instances of SCP 421 17-1
overpower the ship and neutralize
command in the seconds that follow any
witness of the horror that the men
aboard the HMS Hood experienced is
forever in tuned in the watery grave of
the British vessel as the ship is sunk
by a volley of Munitions fire from the
combined might of the German Fleet some
men attempting to jump overboard and
swim to safety are dragged down by their
legs by the mutated instances of SCP
4217 and pulled under lungs filling with
seawat as they scream until their breath
is no more in disbelief the crew of HMS
Prince of Wales decides to retreat in
the days that followed at the bequest of
foundation members the British royal
Navy launches a full-scale Armada to
hunt down and neutralize the bismar
though SCP 427 sustained little damage
in the previous encounter the ship began
leaking a black oil-like substance
thought by SCP researchers to be an
organic waste product of SCP 421
17-b the Allied Naval forces are able to
follow the trail to the coast of France
where under the lead of HMS King George
V British warships surround the German
vessel and opened fire this time they
were ready with approval from the 05
Council Foundation members provide the
British forces with enhanced Munitions
and Armament capable of overwhelming SCP
4217 theological defenses on the eve of
battle it appears to the Allied Forces
that the psionic field generated by SCP
4217 is too great as the naval company
find it difficult to land targeted
assaults on the German vessel after
losing several smaller vessels to the
Colossal appendages of SCP 4217
Foundation members on board authorized
the use of a redacted SCP it is brought
in to deactivate SCP 4217 psionic field
the tide of The Battle Turns and after a
fierce battle SCP 4217 becomes immobile
and unable to return fire Relentless the
British continued their bombardment
until the artillery mun misss on the
ship explode into a giant Fireball
flooding the ship's compartments with
the noxious fumes of the mutogenic
compound its crew members either jump
overboard or are engulfed in the cloud
of gas the British vessels capture any
survivors and watch as SCP 4217 slowly
sinks below the waves down to the depths
of the ocean where it would lay dormant
for the next 48 years SCP 427's 121
surviving crew members were captured and
interrogated most of the low-ranking
German soldiers were released to British
custody 109 of them having their memory
wiped by Foundation staff 12 remaining
members of the crew were sent to site 23
for further detention and advanced
interrogation and 74 of the instances of
s SCP
42171 the mutated subjects were
recovered and sent to site 23 for
further observation it was thought that
on that day SCP 4217 was deemed
neutralized and no longer a matter
matter of priority the Bismark sunk into
memory and myth it was only until the
recent Resurgence of SCP 4217 that the
foundation saw the need to collect as
much information on the organism
inhabiting SCP 4217 daa as possible
decades old manuscripts and ledgers were
pulled from hundreds of viable sources
from the intelligence then gathered
Foundation members have come to the
hypothesis that the entity powering the
vessel known as the bismar has what is
believed to be extra planetary origin
World War III era documents uncovered
between Commander Carl reuter of the
German obscur cor and a doctor Hans
Meyer indicated discovery of an organic
life form of Unknown Origin found in a
crashed aircraft near feldberg Park in
the black forest mountain range in
Germany further correspondents with
obscura Corp members Otto Schmidt and
Dietrich clner indicate that researchers
were conducting trials on the creatures
ability to create psionic fields and to
control or confuse enemy subjects within
its range with a letter from dietr clner
suggesting the creature could be used as
a power source for an unspecified engine
further evidence of SCP 4217 DB's
extraplanetary origin can be found in a
1993 incident between Foundation naval
ship scps nimed and SCP
4217 this is the only incident on record
where contact was established with the
creature classified as SCP 4217 --b on
July 22nd SCP 4217 had reappeared off
the coast of Britain anticipating
hostility scps nemed scps ceser and scps
partholon were instructed to close in on
SCP 427's location with orders to subdue
The Vessel if necessary however on this
occasion SCP 4217 did not appear to be
after any vessel it was simply drifting
along at Sea no propulsion engines
active noticing the change in SCP 427's
Behavior Captain Kurt Wagner decided to
withhold military engagement and
investigate SCP 427's Behavior sailing
within 200 M of the bismar the scps
nemed attempted radio contact with the
German vessel after repeated attempts at
communication the crew were met with
only silence and static chatter giving
up Captain Wagner puts down the radio
receiver when suddenly the sound of
music is heard playing over the speakers
of a ship the tune is the national
anthem of Nazi Germany the captain
hailes The Vessel again repeating his
attempts at communication do you do you
understand me at first only static can
be heard then came a reply you
ship the ominous voice could be heard
from the speakers the captain hesitated
for a moment members of The Crew looking
at each other with apprehension the
captain replied confirming themselves as
a ship and then asking if SCP 4217 knew
what it was and where it came from what
followed was the crew of the scps nemid
receiving a video feed from SCP
4217 featuring a high volume of images
in Rapid succession among them were
images of German cities Adolf Hitler's
telecast of the 1936 Olympics an unknown
structure in outer space and an
increasing repetition images of the
planet Jupiter particularly the giant
storm on Jupiter known to the public as
the Great Red Spot or SCP 2399 as
Foundation members know it the
transcript of the radio communication
between Captain Wagner and SCP 2417
stops when the video feed begins to
focus heavily on images of Jupiter SCP
427's responses become more erratic and
agitated as it repeats the words storm
cloud and red the markings on its hole
beginning to light up and the under
water Shadows of its tentacles beginning
to create whirlpools of displacement
under the bow of the ship a shrill
shrieking begins to flood out of the
speakers followed by a high piercing
high pitched beeping sound that
overloads the communication equipment
causing Sparks to fly as crew members
cover their ears and hide under control
panels the scps nemed barely escapes as
SCP 4217 becomes hostile using its
massive tendril-like appendages to
assail the naval combatants firing its
armament in all directions after a
fierce battle the foundation Naval
forces were able to neutralize and
subdue SCP
4217 no further attempts at
communication have been recorded to keep
the veil of secrecy Foundation members
constructed a replica ship to be sunk
and intentionally rediscovered by
oceanographer Robert Ballard in
1989 any recent sightings of the Nazi
era Bismark are flagged as
misidentification by SCP staff for now
Foundation members continue to monitor
the the behavior of SCP
4217 and protect the public from its
existence you're on a road trip the kind
that stretches over days on end and you
need to make multiple stops along the
way to refuel the car and yourself the
last time you remember stopping to get
more gas and a bite to eat was back in
Wyoming and now you're in the heart of
Montana thankfully like an oasis in the
desert you see the town of Clearwater
off in the distance it's a vibrant
welcoming little place
a perfect slice of classic small town
Americana you took a similar trip last
year and vaguely remember stopping at
Clear Water that time too and you're
glad to be back in particular you
remember the old Prairie Diner a folksy
little place with the most delicious
Huckleberry pie you ever tasted perhaps
it's about time for you to give it
another try you fill up your tank and
stop at the diner the food tastes just
as good as you remember but one thing is
off the entire staff seems to have
changed changed it is the exact same
Diner you ate at a year ago no doubt
about that but it looks like everyone
from the weight staff to the cashier to
the cooks have all been replaced you try
your best not to think about it after
all businesses are allowed to replace
their staff but the longer you sit in
the diner the more uncomfortable the
feelings become you need to ask someone
just to push away the fears that you're
not going crazy when the waiter passes
by you compliment the food and mention
you ate here last year too you asked the
unfamiliar waiter if they had worked
here back then they confirm that yes
they've always worked here and so has
everybody else the diner is a family
business you leave town not too long
after that feeling vaguely unsettled and
as a voice on the radio warns about the
incoming rain you tell yourself that you
never want to return to the town of
Clearwater Montana as you leave the
memory of the Town seems to fade from
your mind in real time but little do you
know the people of clear water will will
never be able to leave ever it's because
something horrifying will happen in
Clear Water every single year and that
thing is known to the SCP Foundation as
SCP
3300 this annual anomalous event is
clear water's own local curse always
occurring around mid June while many of
the mechanics of this event still elude
the foundation's understanding the
outcome is well documented every single
inhabitant of the town is replaced by a
person who didn't previously exist while
some elements may carry over from their
original counterparts every person
involved will simply be a whole new
person with no memories of the change or
who they once were the process known as
SCP 3300 lasts between 6 and 18 days and
once the process has begun it's
impossible for any Outsiders to
intervene it begins with rain a light
dreary drizzle at first but each day the
rain gets worse soon it's a storm and
then a malstrom flooding hurricanes
tornadoes all centered around clear
water but cutting off neatly just beyond
it what happens in Clear Water remains
in Clear Water and when the process has
concluded and The Sun Shines once more
everybody has been changed whenever the
foundation has tried to send Personnel
or equipment into clear water during SCP
3300 one of two things has happened in
the more favorable scenarios those
attempting to enter clear water have
simply appeared appeared on the other
side of the city limits in the less
positive instances personnel and
Equipment have been lost forever within
there is no stopping or even
understanding SCP 3300 according to
Foundation records clear water has been
around at least as long as the
foundation itself perhaps even longer
clear water has been able to undergo its
yearly nightmare without intrusion due
to a unique Cognito hazardous effect
which creates a kind of mental block
around memories of the town for
Outsiders you won't forget clear water
per se but you will find it increasingly
hard to focus on like something you can
only ever see out of the corner of your
eye there is no saving the people of
clear water the horror will play out
again and again and again the foundation
has no firsthand knowledge of what
happens in Clear Water during those
horrifying 18 days but one account they
have hints at a terrifying possibility
during an Excursion into Clear Water the
foundation man managed to collect a
diary belonging to a woman named
Margaret Lane to the best of our
knowledge Margaret Lane no longer exists
but if the contents of her diary aren't
to be believed then what goes on in
Clear Water during SCP 3300 is far worse
than we ever imagined Margaret first
started her diary not long before SCP
3300s 1995 iteration began she was in
the middle of a tumultuous time in her
life freshly clean from alcohol and drug
addiction forced to live live with her
antagonistic mother and having peculiar
and distressing dreams in the first
Dream Margaret recorded she was someone
else a woman living in a small Hut
perhaps a century ago or more it was
plague time she was looking down upon
her daughter bedan her skin covered in
painful looking red blotches her husband
was already dead that's when another man
enters a healthy man he tells her that
he's found their salvation and then the
dream ended Margaret woke up to a gray
dreary day there were clouds on the
horizon the rain was coming it drizzled
for the next few days before getting
more intense as one would expect from an
SCP 3300 cycle of course nothing seemed
out of place to Margaret life carried on
she continued to stay clean resisting
the offers of her old dealer though her
relationship with her mother remained
Frosty the rain started to get worse as
voices on the radio insisted that
conditions would continue to become more
severe over the next few days they tried
their best to maintain normality
Margaret invited some friends Jared Sam
Mike and Isabelle to come over and play
DND D at her place that was when all
hell broke loose while the group role
played there was a furious banging at
the door like whoever was knocking was
trying to bash the door down when
Margaret's mom opened the door to
investigate the commotion she saw that
an entire family was standing there a
father a mother and two young children
the father immediately began furiously
asking why all these strangers were in
his house when Margaret's mother tried
to tell him that this wasn't his house
he became increasingly agitated and
walked straight into the home Margaret's
friends attempted to subdue him but he
threw them off displaying a supernal
strength Margaret's mom ran in with a
golf club and struck the mysterious man
in the chest there was a nasty Splat but
he didn't seem to react the golf club
was just embedded in his chest having
broken the skin and sunken in in but
there was no blood just dripping water
the father then pulled the golf club out
of his chest and began beating
Margaret's mother to death with it all
while repeating my house again and again
while his wife and children watched with
broad Sunny Smiles in the rain somehow
Margaret knew that her mother was beyond
saving and that there was no way of
defeating these things in a physical
confrontation all they could do was run
out to Jared's van with the rest of the
group and high tail it to the police
station but when they arrived at the
station the doors were barred and it
appeared empty as the torrential rain
hammered down from above there was
nothing left to do but drive out of town
and try to escape whatever Madness was
going on here but that was easier said
than done they drove for what seemed
like hours on end as the rain and the
howling wind persisted Jared had been
injured during the fight with the
strange family and his health
deteriorated further as the drive
stretched on they should have left the
town of clear water a long time ago but
it seemed like they were nowhere it
wasn't long before Jared was lying dead
in the back of the van and now there
were only four of them left they kept
driving afraid grieving hungry and tired
and Margaret took the opportunity to
sleep it was no time to rest but she was
so exhausted that she had no choice
Margaret had a continuation of her
earlier dream the different her the
dream her was laying the plague ridden
body of her daughter in the river but
she wasn't the only one all the Villages
of her settlement were placing the
bodies of their dead in the river as the
water washed around them and through
them the bodies became one with the
water and then they became the water the
water was everything when Margaret awoke
it was to the horrifying sounds of
bubbling and boiling that's when she saw
that Jared's body was dissolving now not
dissolving evaporating it was bubbling
and convulsing in like it was made of
water until the entire thing burst into
a Cascade of hot steam after that
Margaret and the others left the vehicle
and refused to get back inside nothing
was making sense it was like something
out of a nightmare as they walked the
rain hammered down upon them they
couldn't have been walking for more than
a mile when they crashed into something
it was a sign welcome to clearw waterer
it was like that the town itself had
drawn them back Mike refused to return
to the town of his own well and began
walking in the other direction moments
later he was walking back towards them
in silence though he never intended to
SCP 3300 had distorted his path and
brought him back it was clear that Mike
was shaken to the core by the experience
but they had to press on they would head
to the grocery store for food and then
to a sporting goods store where they
could hopefully grab some guns to fight
the violent altered people who'd somehow
appeared with the rain but things didn't
go to plan or what little plan there
even was Mike shot himself on the first
night at Dirk Sporting Goods leaving
only Margaret Sam and Isabelle alive
perhaps one of the most terrifying
details of Mike's death was the fact he
didn't even bleed instead the gaping
exit wound in the back of his head was
just full of water water was all that
seemed to be left of them Sam seemingly
driven to the Edge by the sight of
Mike's death grabbed a hunting knife to
perform an experiment she'd cut into her
own skin and was horrified to see only
water dripping out they'd all been
changed and they didn't know why that's
when the survivors noticed something
else there were people standing outside
in the rain hundreds of them not a
single one they could recognize all new
people waiting Sam said only one word
outside before walking out of the
hunting goods store and disappearing
into the crowd in the rain never to be
seen Again Margaret mused that perhaps
in the end she had the right idea to be
taken killed erased or change would be
inevitable in the final entry in
Margaret's diary dreams blend with
reality as her mind finally gives out
from the terror she realizes in her
final moments that there is no way out
there is no Escape there is only water
water is eternal the rain is eternal all
will be changed and given the fact that
no trace of Margaret was ever found save
for her diary all her fears turned out
to be right she was taken and replaced
by SCP 3300 just as will inevitably
happen to all the current citizens of
clear water the next time as CP 3300
rolls around it will be as inevitable
and as indifferent to those it affects
as tomorrow sunrise you cannot change
the rain but believe us in Clearwater
Montana the rain can change you you're
right in the middle of one of the
hottest Summers on record the days are
filled with bright scorching sun and
Searing heat and you've been laying
around with your air conditioning on
full blast just to try and cool yourself
off sadly it's not really working and
the heat is becoming way too much but
then you remember there's this married
couple that lives near you with no kids
and they happen to have a swimming pool
in their yard normally they keep to
themselves they'd never let you use
their pool but they've gone out of town
for a few days besides the heat is
killing you you're sure that the
neighbors wouldn't mind if you just took
a quick dip as long as you clean up
after yourself they probably wouldn't
even notice you were even there
cautiously you make your way to their
house it's an unremarkable Place similar
to most of the other houses in the
suburb of New Mexico after checking that
there's nobody else around you climb the
2 m High cinder block wall that stands
around the back Garden as you drop to
your feet sweaty and panting from the
unrelenting summer heat you see it the
pool your salvation water never looks so
appealing immediately you step Barefoot
across the sunscorch tiles and sit on
the edge legs in the water it's cool and
refreshing perfect for a day as hot as
today you're already changed in wearing
your swim trunks so it doesn't take long
for you to paddle out to the middle of
the pool letting that chilled clean
water cool you off as you're taking a
dip you notice the pool's Jets turning
on automatically it's a little bit odd
but you shrug it off that couple clearly
shelled out for a pool with a lot of
fancy bells and whistles but extra
features aren't why you're here you came
because if you didn't then you could
have melted under all that sunlight
floating on the surface of the water you
relax with your arms behind your head
and close your eyes you don't have time
to realize that coming here was a
mistake instead you start to feel
relaxed so calm so tranquil you're one
with the water around you now it's
almost as though you could just
disappear so you do the police never
find any trace of you everyone else
simply writes it off as a random
disappearance there's not even so much
as a scrap of your body left in the pool
just the clear clean water why because
the swimming pool you decided to take a
cooling dip in wasn't an ordinary pool
it was SCP 242 but don't worry you won't
be the last to make that costly mistake
what you didn't know is that the married
couple who live in that house are
secretly a pair of SCP Foundation
doctors the house isn't even theirs the
foundation procured it after the former
owner a retired out ofate landlord
strangely vanished he had been
struggling to find anyone to rent the
place so he eventually decided to give
up on the property game and move in
there himself after 3 days he was never
seen again now that house has only one
rule that must be followed above all
else do not swim in the pool SCP 242 is
at least to the untrained eye just an
average swimming pool a decent 9 m in
length 4 and a half wide and it holds
around 53,000 L of sterile pool water
like we mentioned before it's even got
some Nifty features like water jets a
dual waterfall and a built-in vacuum
unit for sucking out any imp impurities
and we mean any impurities you see SCP
242 does go by another name the
self-cleaning pool and while that might
not sound as for boing or dramatic as
the Scarlet king or the wendigo skull or
the horrifying nasty dude of ultimate
Badness okay we made that last one up we
can assure you that you don't ever want
to suffer the fate of taking a swim in
this pool there was an incident a while
ago recorded by the foundation through a
secret hidden camera the house where SCP
242 can be found had been left vacant
for a time and once again some
opportunists decided to take advantage
of the empty swimming pool this time it
was a couple a man and a woman in their
early 20s they climbed up the back wall
undressed and even stole a couple of
plastic inflatable rafts from a shed in
The house's backyard the water jets
switched themselves on startling the
girl but her boyfriend told her not to
worry the filter clean the pool was
probably just on an automatic timer
right surely it wouldn't have been
anything to worry about after swimming
together for around 24 minutes the
couple both agreed that the water felt
warm tingly even both of them climbed
onto their rafts eventually falling
asleep while still holding each other's
hands but almost half an hour after the
Jets had started something caused the
two rafts to burst the couple awoke
startled by the loud pop of the
splitting Inflatables and being plunged
back into the water the pool around them
immediately began frothing violently
deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed
in fear and Agony both of them tried to
desperately swim to the edge hoping to
leave the pool and get to safety but
unfortunately that plan didn't work
before they could reach the edge the man
and the woman were Pulled Under the
surface of the Raging Water their limbs
thrashing as they still tried in vain to
escape eventually they vanished under
the crimson in bloody water the frothing
slowly began to calm and the red in the
pool dissipated once again becoming
clear after 48 seconds the couple were
never seen again and a cover story was
leaked to the Press by the SCP
Foundation 2 weeks after they went
missing according to them the pair had
eloped together somewhere in Mexico if
only that sounds a lot nicer than what
actually happened to them so this
swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties that much is obvious but what
exactly are those properties how exactly
does SCP 242 work is it an
interdimensional Gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if
they spend too long swimming in it or is
the swimming pool itself a sentient
carnivorous creature that lures humans
in only to devour them maybe the water
is teeming with invisible flesh eating
piranhas that can strip the meat from
the bone in a matter of seconds well
good guesses all around but actually
it's none of of these it's unclear what
causes the pool's anomalous effects it
could be a property that is completely
unique to the water contained in SCP 242
or maybe it's down to the exact shape
and measurements of the pool itself it
could even be a combination of both but
whatever the cause the result is always
the same when any object substance or
even living organism is placed in SCP
242 it will be entirely Rewritten on a
molecular level the genetic an atomic
structure will fall apart and the
subject will be transmuted into sterile
water in fact not just clean water but
water that remains sterile even when
removed from the pool if you took a cup
of SCP 242s water and mixed something
like food coloring into it the food
coloring would not be absorbed into the
water instead staying as one non-missile
bubble this process doesn't happen
instantly though it can vary depending
on how contaminated or complex the
substance placed in SCP 242 is for
example water sampled from a nearby
River was sterilized and purified by the
pool in about 7 minutes a sample of
stagnant pond water riddled with various
diseases and germs took 11 minutes
longer what about 50,000 liters of colar
well that one took a little longer 12
long days to be exact but was still
turned into pure sterile water and as
for a living human being maybe ask that
couple that took a dip in the
self-cleaning pool the foundation is
naturally fascinated with the pool and
after extensive examination they have
determined that as SCP 242 doesn't seem
to have been intentionally designed for
the specific anomalous function it
performs the components of SCP 242
beyond the pool itself the filter the
vacuum the pipes none of these parts nor
anything about the swimming pool's
design appear to be responsible for
disintegrating matter until only water
remains you might have noticed that in
the case of the ill- fated couple who
took a swim in SCP 242 the water jets
and waterfall features switch themselves
on automatically before the pair's Grim
demise somehow these features are able
to activate without the need for
electricity as disconnecting the pool
from a power source will not stop the
Jets and waterfall from coming on once a
non-water substance is placed into SCP
242 the same goes for the pool vacuum
which apparently cannot be J jammed or
malfunction even when the bottom of the
pool is a wash with viscous liquids like
that colar the vacuum will continue to
operate as normal scrubbing away at the
floor of SCP 242 the one part of the
selfcleaning pool that doesn't work as
you would expect is the water filtration
system there is never any water being
cycled into the pool nor out of it as a
matter of fact the pipes connecting to
the filtration system have all been
removed then again who needs a
filtration system when your backyard
swimming pool can just spontaneously
reduce anything to clean water but that
raises another frightening thought
everything that the pool has ever taken
and converted is still in there animals
objects people just swimming around you
perhaps if they could still think they'd
scream and shout and tell you to get
away to run while you still can but the
second your skin touches the water
you're destined to be with them forever
and ever and ever it's enough to send a
liquid chill down your spine okay so if
it's not the actual physical pool that
causes these anomalous effects that must
mean it's something in the water right
perhaps some microscopic flesh devouring
microb or some ancient curse that was
placed on the water before it was used
to fill up the pool surely if you took a
cup of water out of SCP 242 it would
still break down structures on a
molecular level leaving only more
sterile water while the researchers
working at the SCP Foundation thought
much of the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact
properties of SCP 242s water one test
involves submerging two d-class test
subjects each wearing an atmospheric
dive suit into SCP 242 the goal was to
determine if it was safe to consume the
water from SCP 242 while both inside and
outside of the pool test subject a was
lowered into the water and instructed to
drink from a metal straw by their mouth
the eye pieces of their goggles were
blacked out so they couldn't see what
they were drinking from subject B filled
a barrel with the same water from SCP
242 and then was made to put on an
atmospheric dive suit but instructed to
stay out of the pool test subject a was
told to drink directly from the pool
remarking that the water was warm and
had a bit of a noticeable chemical
aftertaste but was otherwise normal then
test subject B drank some of the same
water from the barrel apparently it was
cool and tasted of well nothing just
like water usually does after a moment
more of drink subject a began belching
finding that they had uncontrollable gas
the water had begun to feel warmer
stinging the subject's mouth while for
subject B the water from the barrel
stayed cool and refreshing the
foundation doctors overseeing the
experiment instructed test subject a to
keep drinking which they did until it
felt even hotter to The Taste one of the
DCL class's fillings even fell out and
eventually the structural Integrity of
subject A's dive suit failed presumably
disintegrated by the water from SCP 242
after a few muffled screams and gurgling
noises test subject a wasn't heard from
again and we can all probably guess why
as for subject B they kept drinking from
the barrel suffering no adverse effects
even after 17 long hours there were no
noticeable psychological or physical
changes even their urine showed no Trace
of abnormality the water from SCP 242
left in the barrel evaporated as normal
leaving behind no residue or any
indicator as to why taking the water out
of the pool made it safer to drink than
the same water in the pool perhaps the
moral of the story is to just be careful
where you choose to take a swim
otherwise it could be your last 40 years
ago a US Navy exploratory vessel landed
on a chain of islands in the South
Atlantic just 2,000 Mi off the coast of
Argentina in other words the middle of
nowhere yet on this far off set of rocks
afloat in the middle of the ocean they
discovered a vast array of strange
wildlife and plant species that resemble
little of what they left behind on the
mainland could this be a treasure Trove
of undiscovered species they wondered
hoping to capitalize on the Discovery a
reconnaissance team of researchers was
sent out to explore some of the islands
on foot and what they found did not
disappoint from endangered species of
birds to plant life and vegetation that
looked like it belonged on Mars they
found a dizzying array of new and
exciting examples of evolutionary oddies
that would fill a library but
unfortunately their Jubilation was cut
short attempting to collect soil samples
they dug into the ground and soon
discovered that what they were standing
on wasn't actually ground at all the
Navy scientists soon discovered the
rocky terrain they were exploring was
actually made up entirely of organic
matter as per the standard protocol the
SCP Foundation was forced to silenc the
US Navy research vessel after its
Discovery with the okay from the US
government the ship was torpedoed and
sunk to the bottom of the ocean with all
hands on deck in the name of protecting
the greater good of the masses a tragedy
at sea for the sake of preventing
worldwide pandemonia from there the
foundation took over with the
containment procedures of what would
eventually come to be known as SCP 169
better known by its nickname the
Leviathan The Leviathan is a Biblical
creature of mythical proportions said to
be able to boil the Seas and create
Earth ending floods with just a whip of
its massive continent spanning body it
is unclear if SCP 169 has the ability to
do these things though given its massive
size which Foundation researchers
estimate to be somewhere between 2,000
and 8,000 km it's easy to see how
something that big moving at any speed
could be devastating for the coastal
regions of the world although we use the
word contain it is impossible for SCP
staff to ever contain something of such
massive size surveillance and monitoring
are about all we can do for now that and
hope it never wakes up and decides that
we're on the menu it was thought to be
relatively smooth sailing until one
incident changed everything Dr Hart
turned off the video monitor and faced
the assembled members of MTF gamma 6
also known as the Deep feeders renowned
for their specialization in the tracking
of deep sea and oceanic anomalies the
room was dark and each team member was
sitting in Shadow but still Dr Hart
could see the seriousness on their faces
I'm sure you're wondering why I called
you here at such short notice he said on
the screen behind him he put up a NASA
satellite picture of a small set of
Rocky Islands you see this little island
chain here well it wasn't there a week
ago he paused rubbing his forehead from
lack of sleep at 8:05 a.m. today we
recorded another auditory anomaly
emitting from SCP 169 this one was much
louder and longer than the one recorded
in 1997 by the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration the one known
as the bloop back then it was easy to
brush off as some ice breaking off of a
continental shelf and scraping against
the seaf floor it's not so easy to cover
up anymore these auditory emissions from
SCP 169 are beginning to grow more
frequent more than that increased
seismic activity around the archipelago
on the creature's back indicates that
the rate at which the creature is
breathing is also up typically the rate
at which the creature takes what we are
assuming to be a breath is once every 3
months the rate has increased to once
every 3 weeks for as long as we've been
monitoring SCP 169 it's been a drift
along the southern Atlantic never moving
more than a kilm a week that behavior is
slowly beginning to change it doesn't
sound like much but something that big
even moving just a fraction of that
faster means 100t tidal waves for the
entire South American Coastline We Fear
the creatures showing signs of waking up
if this is true it could mean a
cataclysm for the hundreds of Nations
around the world Millions H even
billions could be wiped off the face of
the Earth if this thing just flips its
body too fast in the wrong direction to
put it to scale this monster is about
the size of the Caribbean maybe even
bigger as far as we know the doctor then
pulled out a decanter of whiskey and
poured himself a glass swallowing the
entire pore in one go in an appalling
breach of workplace professionalism
seriously an XK Class end of the world
scenario is still no excuse for drinking
on the job we're talking about an
extinction level event a Bonafide XK
Class end of thee World scenario 1000t
tsunami wave stretching as far as the
eye can see from either end of The
Horizon the last time SCP 169 stirred it
created the Mediterranean in fact the
legends of the biblical flood Noah's Ark
the same story can be found in every
civilization and culture around the
world so maybe they were on to something
it is to this end I call you all here to
save the world from the next great flood
he paused for a moment as the room took
in the gravity of the situation the more
we can learn about SCP 169 the better
right now we know squat for one we've
never seen just how deep the body of the
creature goes or what's under it the
pressure has been too great for our
current model submarines until now after
reinforcing on Nemo 1 deep sea
submersible with theurgical runes the
Integrity of its ho has increased
exponentially your mission will be to
travel as far down and as close to the
creature as possible if it breathes then
there must be gills or lungs there must
be some basic biological facts we need
to understand if we're going to survive
extinction our only recourse is to find
a way to sedate the creature and if that
doesn't work then God help us all just
12 hours later deep in the waters of the
Southern Atlantic a massive submersible
ship was diving down into the depths of
the deep ocean looking for a way to stop
the end of the world agent ja 6-1 a
member of deep feeders looked out of the
massive viewing Port as the ship slowly
descended alongside the rocky trench
that made up the body of SCP 169 behind
him was Dr heart sporting a white 5:00
shadow and a red nose from a night of
drinking to calm his nerves the entire
crew were silent in awe as the giant
flood lights of the ship brushed over
the Barnacle covered surfaces of the
undersea mountain they progressed slowly
reaching each milestone in depth with
caution knowing that one wrong move
could destabilize the pressure in their
ship J 6-1 murmured the word scales what
asked Dr Hart I've been watching the
patterns of The Ridges as we sink down
they look like scales giant segments
it's hard to see at first because
they're so covered in Barnacles and
sediment but I'm sure of it they're
giant armored scales the way lobsters or
crabs have armored exoskeletons
interesting the doctor said scratching
his chin arthopods have segmented
armored bodies this means we might be
looking at some sort of evolutionary
hybrid some sort of aquatic mammo such
as a whale or dolphin one that has
developed armored segmented scales
similar to that of a crustation the
doctor crossed his arms to think the
closest thing we have on the fossil
record of this magnitude is an armored
fish from the Cretaceous Period but even
that's way too small to compare to this
this thing has an entire ecosystem on
its back how old is it ask the agent
well now that you mention it given the
impossible age of the creature an
arthropod would make sense
lobsters and other crustations don't age
conventionally you see they are
effectively Immortal in fact they
actually die because they continue to
grow until their bodies can't hold up
their humongous size anymore yet SCP 169
just kept growing the doctor trailed off
thinking to himself Dr Hart still lost
in thought turned to walk to the back of
the submersible as ja's 6-1 followed he
said as much to himself as to the agent
the creature's old the Geological Survey
conducted when SCP 169 was first
discovered carbon dated the specimen to
over 541 million years old as you can
probably surmise that's too old for any
living being the results had to be
incorrect and yet I checked them myself
more than once and numbers do not lie
The Entity predates our civilization H
it predates complex life forms on this
planet as we know it from an
evolutionary standpoint it doesn't make
any sense the agent confused asked
doctor how could something so big even
come into existence very little of our
planet is actually land mass it's a
wonder we call it Earth most of this
planet is water we aren't looking at a
creature that's on our planet agent we
are on each planet just then a flurry of
alarms and sensors began to go off at
the bridge of the ship the team
scrambled through their stations
checking off monitors and shouting
readings to each other the ship's
thermal sensors are detecting a massive
rise in temperature transmitting power
to Cooling systems we have activity
Northwest of our location sonar has
something bigheaded in our way we need
to dive now the ship lged forward nose
first as everyone on board held on to
their seats the restraints keeping them
from falling forward just outside of the
viewing Port Dr Hart could see an
enormous scaled appendage moving fast in
their location we need to steer the ship
clear of the talons revert all power to
the thrusters get us out of the way the
doctor yelled don't you think I'm doing
that the captain shouted back the ship
jolted sideways and downwards as an
immense wave of pressure came over the
submersible putting six G's of force on
its occupants ja 6-1 yelped out of fear
as the ship came close to crashing into
what appeared to be the edge of a
Titanic Talon the size of the Empire
State Building following the encounter
the part of the ship bordering the
reinforced glass of the viewing Port
began to Glow bright red it's boiling
the water around us one of the crew
members cried out it's not boiling
anything it's just Cavit due to the
pressure reduction in the water the
updated ruins on the ship's Hall should
keep us safe we just need to cool our
heads stay focused on the mission bottom
feters after several moments of holding
their breaths the crew of Nemo 1 began
to relax as their Pace returned to a
slow descent along the side of the
underwater Behemoth before long The
Vessel was no longer traveling straight
down but starting to curve under the
creature traveling north towards the
theoretical head of SCP 169 after
several hours the ship Came Upon giant
fissures in the Rocky exterior of the
creature these massive vent likee
structures appeared stiff but slowly
they opened and closed over the span of
weeks these were the respiratory organs
of the organism clocking it at over 2
mil underneath the surface of the ocean
the crew carefully began entering the
smaller pod-like submersibles that
detached from the main ship J 6-1
entered his pod and strapped on the
haptic gloves that would give him
control of the pod robotic arms he and a
team of three other volunteers had
agreed to undergo The Dangerous Mission
of attaching artificial chemical
emission machines that could be
programmed to release anesthetic gas
into SCP 169 respiratory system on
command remotely the emission machines
could be refueled manually whenever the
contents ran out it was an ingenious
solution Dr Hart came up with when
thinking of his time studying sharks as
a marine biologist it attack the fins of
sharks by capturing them and bringing
the specimens on the deck of their boat
from there the scientist would drill a
radio frequency emitter onto the fin of
the shark when he had first seen this
practice as a young college student Dr
Hart was afraid the process was harming
the shark but later he learned it was
designed in a way to not be harmful to
the specimen and eventually the tag
would fall off after enough data on the
shark's movement was collected except
these tags would not be falling off he
thought they could not for the sake of
all mankind this had to work the doctor
pressed a button on the receiver of the
radio and spoke J 6-1 what's your status
pressure's holding all signs look good
6-2 precious holding all good 6-3 all
clear Captain 6-4 there was silence just
6 for do you copy all clear doc sorry my
mic was muted on Route and ready to do
this thing Dr Hart sighed in relief and
slowly reclined in his chair watching
the pods move closer to the large open
openings on SCP 169 side one by one the
robotic arms used underwater torches to
drill into the thick rocklike
exoskeleton of the creature screwing in
complex million-dollar equipment that
was both waterproof and could withstand
the immense pressure at such a depth
under the ocean as the minutes turned to
hours Dr Hart couldn't help but feel
anxiety for the safety of his crew and
the success of the mission but before
long the pods began to return one by one
to the mothercraft each completing the
segment of work with which they were
tasked the last pod still working was J
6-1 whose robotic arm was in the process
of rotating a large industrial siiz
screw J 6-1 had all but finished when
suddenly a low Rumble could be felt
shaking the larger submersive Dr Hart's
voice came crackling over the radio get
back to the ship now Z 6-1 wrapped in
deep focus on his task replied I'm just
about finished just packing up my tool
belt leave it return to the ship now
that's an order jez Jesus what's wrong
it's not like this is the end of the
world said the agent chuckling over his
radio an earpiercing echo sent shock
waves through the depths of the ocean
around the submersible the waves rumbled
with the sound of SCP 169s voice similar
to the sound of a large whale but
Amplified by a million the sound sent
all the crew members falling to the
floor as the ship experienced severe
damage from the burst of pressure
slightly cracking the glass viewport and
sending smoke flooding into the small
Bridge of the ship gas masks shouted Dr
Hart as they all down breathing
apparatus SCP 169 is waking up begin
activation of the chemical emission
machines we need to sedate it now the
Leviathan is waking up we need to stop
it shouted Dr Hart just then he looked
back and noticed J 6 d1's Pod was gone J
6-1 what's your position J 6-1 where are
you s Sona has him drifting off deeper
into the ocean behind us he must have
gotten knocked off SC SCP 169 by the
Shar wave but Dr Hart would wouldn't
have it he didn't want any more blood on
his hands reverse thrusters turn us
around and get to him we're not losing
anyone but the breach in the hull it'll
home that's what the ruins are for the
outside of the submersible began to Glow
a slight blue as the ship system started
to come back online to full capacity and
alarm system started to turn off and
Report normal pressure readings before
long the nemo1 had caught up to ja 61's
pod and retrieved the agent but have
been knocked unconscious by the shock
wave once the agent was back on the main
ship the doctor turned his attention
back to the monitors making sure the
installations they drilled into the
creature were functional slowly the
machines came online to full power and
the speed at which SCP 169 had been
moving began to slow ever so slightly
the team all watched the viewport in
silence as a steady stream of anesthetic
gas was pumped into the respiratory
system of the gigantic living myth in
front of them after a few moments of
waiting the doctor spoke I think it
worked he said with a smile smile the
crew erupted in cheers as they radioed
control back up on land that the mission
had been a success the message quickly
reached the 05 Council where a red alert
status was de-escalated and the 05
members withdrew from their plan of
leaving the current Earth for that of an
alternate universe the whole crew began
to sing and celebrate the prevention of
the end of the world as Dr Hart simply
stood in front of the massive viewport
watching the mountainous specimen slowly
grow smaller in the distance as the
submersible began and ascending back to
the world above ja 6-1 came over to
congratulate him patting him on the back
we did it he said loosen up the doctor
managed to laugh along in
acknowledgement that we did he said in
relief that we did the two watched the
deep blue ocean in silence taking in the
vastness of the sea perhaps this would
not be the end of it but that day they
had done what the SCP Foundation did
best kick that apocalyptic can a few
miles down the road
and sometimes in the face of the
terrifying and the infinite that's
really the best you can do Jack was
swimming deep underwater wondering why
he had such a pounding headache when
suddenly he had a terrifying realization
he had no idea where he was or what he
was doing there was a nagging feeling
that he must have a specific reason to
be here you don't just end up deep in
the ocean with a diving suit on by
chance yet he had no idea what he was
supposed to be doing he wasn't sure he
cared either he was more worried about
the throbbing pain in his head and the
vision of two eyes staring at him out of
the dark that he couldn't get out of his
mind his heart began to race as he
wondered what to do and how to get help
he was in the middle of the ocean and
appeared to be all alone he couldn't see
anything in the Dark Water except for
this weird gray substance in front of
him maybe he was going to die here alone
without knowing if anyone could even
hear him he began to speak aloud about
how he was consumed by sickness and that
Darkness was all around him this is the
story of one of the most powerful and
dangerous anomalies yet discovered C SCP
3000 before Jack's descent into despair
the SCP Foundation had mandated an
exploratory Expedition off the coast of
Bangladesh after receiving a few strange
reports from locals and fishermen the
foundation suspected an SCP was lurking
in the water and positioned a few
Personnel to investigate the crew
expected danger or maybe even death but
what they got instead was Far stranger
and more ominous all of the men had been
verified to be in sound mental States
when the mission set out but a few of
them reported feeling strange and uneasy
as the submarine descended into the
ocean before long a veteran agent named
Dr Williams began to panic in a way that
was completely out of character he
started sweating profusely shaking and
wouldn't listen to a word of comfort or
reason that anybody tried to offer it
might seem like a relatively normal
reaction for anyone descending into the
depths of the ocean to meet with a
monster that they don't know anything
about but Dr Williams was a seasoned
professional who had been on hundreds of
such missions before there was no
logical reason for him to act like this
although the reaction of Dr Williams was
the most extreme he wasn't the only one
who started to feel strange multiple
agents developed a creeping feeling of
unease that swept over them one of the
calmer men tried to reason with Dr
Williams asking him what was wrong and
if he could explain exactly how he was
feeling that's when things got even
stranger Not only was the doctor
extremely anxious but he now seemed
incapable of giving a real response to
any questions thrown at him he could
only mutter that he was missing
something but he wasn't sure what
knowing that many scps can bend reality
and the human mind many of the Personnel
began to have second thoughts about the
mission and even asked for permission to
call off the mission but they were
mandated to continue so they went on as
the team went deeper and deeper into the
ocean things only got worse even the
previously calmed crew members became
spooked and antsy while the ones who
were already anxious were now sweating
and jittering as for Dr Williams he was
now pacing back and forth around the
submarine saying things nobody could
understand and every time he looked at
his colleagues and his close friends he
seemed to stare straight through them
and would call them by the wrong names
it was as if his mind had moved to a
different dimension whenever someone
asked him to perform his normal duties
he looked more confused than ever still
the team went deeper Dr Williams began
to whimper and say the word no
repeatedly growing louder and louder
until he was screaming and the others
were forced to sedate him just then
something came into view it was what
would come to be known as scp3 000 the
thing was huge so huge that its whole
body couldn't be seen out of the
submarine window it was a horrible eel
looking creature with a head as big as a
town and haunting eyes that Lit Up The
Black Ocean around it but perhaps the
strangest part was this giant eel seemed
to be producing a weird gray liquid even
the sedative wasn't enough to keep Dr
Williams calm anymore there was a
strange blank look in his eyes as if the
light and life had left him and he just
began screaming no repeatedly again and
wouldn't respond to any attempts to calm
him down not that anyone else was very
capable of calming him down at this
point even the crew members that had
been holding up well were starting to
act strangely and nobody could get the
image of these ominous eyes out of their
heads then things went from bad to worse
Williams began screaming and shouting
madly as if he was being tortured by an
unseen Force the men tried to restrain
him but it was no use he began smashing
his head against the submarine window
until it cracked putting the whole
mission in everyone's life at risk he
fell to the ground injured chanting that
there was nothing whatever that meant it
was an emergency scenario they began
applying first aid to Williams as the
submarine ascended to the surface as
quickly as possible before the pressure
of the ocean caused the cracked window
to explode by the time they reached the
surface Williams was dead but there was
something even more chilling than the
circumstances of his death every single
man who had been in that submarine
experienced the same thing on the days
that came afterward the image of the
eel-like creatur's eyes seemed burned in
their mind permanently it would haunt
their waking hours for the rest of their
lives and sleep was no Escape either as
they would appear in both their dreams
and nightmares alike forever a second
mission had to be sent to gather more
information about the strange Beast
already there were many theories and
question marks surrounding SCP 3000 how
big was it really was it sentient what
was the liquid for none of the men who
had been on the previous Mission were
willing to return to the waters but a
new group of Brave recruits volunteered
they were about to find out what so in
history have learned the hard way that
bravery and foolishness are often
mistaken for the same thing this time
the mission would not be in a submarine
but in dive suits in order to observe
the anomaly in even closer detail and to
eliminate the chance of one team member
self- sabotaging the submarine killing
them all they were transported to the
location by boat and the three men
splashed into the ocean they descended
and at first everything was going well
in case anything went wrong the three of
them were tethered together for extra
security but the deeper into the ocean
they swam and the closer they got to SCP
3000's location they got the stranger
things became just like on the last
mission first there were a few minor
cases of confusion one of the team Jack
thought it was his responsibility to
lead the navigation but another Roberto
also thought it was his job in fact
navigation was actually the job of a
third team member air but he seemed to
have forgotten everyone was getting
confused the team listening in on the
conversations at the foundation
headquarters grew increasingly concerned
about what they could hear was everyone
losing their minds hopefully nobody was
about to pull another Dr Williams on
them still the project leads couldn't
afford to tell the men to come back to
the surface the foundation badly needed
any information they could get on this
SCP whatever the cost so they told the
men to press on things only got worse
Roberto was asking to speak to a
colleague who passed away 2 years ago
while the others began to mutter
indistinguishable phrases about eyes and
darkness not too dissimilar to the
ramblings of Dr Williams it increasingly
began to look like a suicide mission
then there was silence what was going on
each of the men had completely lost it
to the point that they cut the tether
that was holding them together all alone
Jack couldn't remember where he was or
why he was here he desperately looked
around to try and gauge his surroundings
but he could only see Darkness all he
could think about was a pair of large
eyes and an overwhelming fear of Despair
and anxiety and this weird gray fluid
that was now floating in front of him
the foundation listened as Jack started
reciting a creepy speech about being on
the edge of nothing in es from Oblivion
with a sickness in his mind and nothing
but a pair of eyes in front of him they
listened in horror as they heard
movement through the radio it sounded
like a huge creature was swimming toward
the men it had to be SCP 3000 but all
three men were too confused to do
anything about the situation or to even
see what was in front of them claiming
they couldn't see anything in the
darkness there was silence for half a
minute with the team listening in
fearing the worst then they heard some
more unintelligible mutterings the men
must be alive but what on Earth was
going on then the gibberish started
again two of the men were screaming that
Jack had just been swallowed whole and
that they were being sucked in too why
couldn't they just swim away it was
chaos but then a few moments later
Roberto spoke into the radio saying he
was floating alone in the middle of the
ocean and had now moved away from the
eyes of SCP 3000 he finally seemed
capable of forming coherent thoughts and
speech after what had just happened
Roberto now had a theory he thought that
somehow it was impossible to think
straight around SCP 3000 when he'd been
close enough to see the eyes Roberto had
felt a throbbing pain in his brain and
been unable to think about anything
perhaps it was something to do with that
mysterious gray liquid even more slime
was coming out of SCP 3000 now and
Roberto was determined to get a sample
despite the warnings from HQ in one
final burst of motivation he swam close
enough to take some of the gray liquid
and put it in a special sample
collection unit that was designed to
float to the surface for collection
later he had acquired some very
important data but he seemed to have
lost all hope of preserving his life
Roberto started telling the team over
the radio that he was dying and that his
heart rate was too high but cautioned
that it would be too dangerous for
anyone to try and rescue him the
Personnel continued to try and
communicate with Roberto to figure out
what was going on but his words had
stopped making any sense until finally
he went quiet minutes turned into hours
hours into days and still there was no
sign of Roberto or the rest of the
divers after 3 days His Radio which had
only been sending a steady stream of
Static finally stopped working
altogether and he was presumed dead
however the sample Roberto had collected
had survived and made it to the hands of
the foundation researchers it turned out
to be a viscous substance now known as
y99 a chemical compound and extremely
strong anesthesia y 99 causes head pain
paranoia fear Panic memory loss and
confusion explaining what happened to Dr
Williams and the diving Trio the
collection of Y 99 might have resulted
in two disastrous missions but there's a
silver lining as the substance ended up
becoming an invaluable tool for the SCP
Foundation its ability to make people
forget what had just happened to them
can be used to eliminate knowledge of
threatening scps among the public it
also helps the foundation staff cope
with the traumatic experiences they
encounter on their missions although
other amnestics can be used for the same
purpose none are as powerful as the one
produced by SCP 3000 before its
Discovery the amnestics used would break
down too quickly not farewell in storage
or cause undesirable side effects the
only problem is the method of sourcing
the only way to obtain y 99 is somewhat
ethically questionable for most people
SCP 3000 produces y99 after eating so
the best way to stock up on it is by
feeding the creature sedated d-class
Personnel from the foundation are sent
on Mission supposedly to observe the
anomaly up close unaware that this
mission is one way only other divers are
then sent later to collect the fluid
from a safe distance and store it of
course it's all for the greater good of
humanity now the foundation protects SCP
3000 as best as it can guard something
hundreds of kilometers long the area is
carefully patrolled and members of the
public are not allowed to enter the part
of the bay where it resides anybody who
accidentally comes into contact is
contained eventually another pair of
foundation doctors went down in a
submarine to try and learn more about
SCP 3000 one became so affected by y 99
that he began hallucinating he started
talking about ananta shesha the king of
serpents in Hinduism anant shesha is
believed to be all that will be left
after the end of the world because it
exists throughout all of time
simultaneously the doctor said he
believed that this was in fact an anesa
that SCP 3000 simply shows us that
eventually everyone dies and Fades into
the darkness of Oblivion right before he
exited the submarine and swam right into
his mouth luckily for now SCP 3000 seems
to be in a sort of hibernation state it
rarely moves and it doesn't hunt
although it will eat when fed but no one
knows when or if it'll wake or what it's
capable of if it does will it destroy
the world or simply drive us all insane
it was just a job you were meant to be
mopping floors and cleaning toilets at
the Johnston labs and pharmaceuticals
Research Center for minimum wage and you
were happy about it grateful for any
kind of employment you didn't even know
that the company signing your checks was
the SCP Foundation an organization
dedicated to securing and containing
anomalies and protecting Humanity from
their negative effects at any cost and
today you're going to find out exactly
how steep that cost can be the Johnston
labs and pharmaceuticals Research Center
isn't actually a research center at all
it's a foundation front business with a
building solely dedicated to the
containment of a single anomaly SCP
3280 but again you're just the janitor
it's not like they would bother telling
you what's being contained here if it
breaks out you won't even know what's
killing you until it's too late it
begins like most classic horror stories
on a dark and stormy night night you're
mopping up a silent hallway whistling a
little tuned to yourself when rain
starts hammering down on the window next
to you not long after you see a bolt of
lightning split the distant Sky followed
by an immense Thunder crack soon after
you hear screaming and panicking From
Below frantic footsteps then the
flashing lights and Sirens you think
back to your employee orientation these
flashing lights and wailing Sirens can
only mean one thing cont mment breach
you run for it not even knowing what
you're running from you bring your mop
and bucket with you perhaps just out of
habit you seek refuge in the only place
in the facility that truly seems to
belong to you the broom closet the alarm
blares as you lock yourself in the
closet you're shaking with Terror and
can hear the screaming of your
colleagues you hear more noises running
scrambling a wet dripping sound gunshots
and then silence all this time you can't
help but wonder why isn't anybody coming
to help us after a while the only thing
you can hear is the rain and the distant
Thunder it's been hours you've only
managed to saave off dehydration by
drinking the filthy water from the mop
sink but at least it seems like the
chaos outside has died down carefully
you open the door and peek out of the
closet Darkness but no detectable
movement now's your chance and you make
a break for it creeping down the hall
the dark hallway is suddenly lit up by
lightning and you can see that there are
bodies everywhere you step over the
corpse of Dr coone one of the few
scientists working here who actually
knew your name if you can make it to the
security office you might be able to
radio for help or maybe access a
computer terminal on the way to the
office you hear another horrific scream
start to echo through the complex before
it's cut off by a Thunderclap you have
to ignore it though and P push on when
you enter the security room you see that
the head security officer Nicholls is
already dead his body has been cut open
from neck to groin gutted the anomaly
whatever it is has already been here you
access the computer terminal and open
the file for SCP
3280 you're warned that as janitorial
staff you have level zero clearance and
as a result information will be omitted
from the files you access it doesn't
matter you press on and open up the file
both the object class and the
description have been redacted you can
only see the special containment
procedures they dictate that 3280 is to
remain contained at the Johnston labs
and pharmaceuticals Research Center
until long-term containment procedures
can be drawn up if the entity ever
reaches Beyond suev 2 the facility
enters full lockdown mode not even
information is allowed in or out of the
facility as this could result in an XK
class end of the world scenario in other
words nobody is coming to save you the
only other information on the page is a
picture of a lightning storm much like
the one you find yourself in right now
lightning flashes in the hall you Dart
around paranoid knowing the anomaly
could be anywhere all you can hear now
is the quiet drip drip drip of blood
coming from the body of security officer
Nicholls whatever this thing had done to
him looked painful you try to remember
him as he was in life and then a
revelation hits you a security officer
probably has a lot better clearance than
a janitor you feel around Nichols
mutilated torso until you find his key
card thankfully Nicholls was the kind of
guy who'd write his password on the
underside of this card so he wouldn't
forget it you easily gain access to the
foundation servers with his login
credentials you now have level two
security clearance the terminal gives
you the option to view security footage
taken throughout the site you're given
access to every camera still working
after the Containment Breach and the
subsequent Carnage you select the camera
feed for the second floor Barracks there
you see researcher Jensen hanging from a
makeshift noose attached to his bunk
there's a puddle underneath his corpse
you access the feed from the second
floor east Wing there you see Dr Emanuel
stumbling down a dark Corridor his
movements are oddly listless like he's
in a trance suddenly there's another
flash of lightning and the crack of
thunder Dr Emanuel clutches his gut in
pain and crumples to the floor you
access the camera feed from the first
floor entrance it seems that the whole
area is flooded is this because of the
storm in a panic many lower tier staff
members had tried to escape defying the
lockdown protocols and the special
containment procedures now they're
floating face down in the water all dead
you access the camera feed from sublevel
2 and see another corpse lying Ling in
the corner he's wearing an orange
jumpsuit d-class no idea why he was down
there the only other notable thing in
the basement was a burst pipe leaking
and spraying more water everywhere with
trembling fingers you select the camera
feed for the first floor cafeteria the
whole room is practically underwater the
only evidence of the massacre that must
have taken place are the fragments of
clothing floating on the surface of the
water that and the fleshy pink slurry
forming at the bottom of the windows it
reminds you of the gooey meat runoff in
chicken nugget factories you close your
eyes and try to Center yourself it's
violent chaos looking at more of it
isn't getting you anywhere instead you
put those new level two security access
credentials to good use and hop back
onto the file for SCP 3280 you think to
yourself there has to be something I can
use on here but even as you wait for the
file to load some part of you knows that
time time is running out for you perhaps
it's the stress or the fear or the
filthy mop water you drank but you're
feeling the pressur start to mount
physically your stomach is beginning to
ache you can see blurry shapes moving in
the corners of your eyes it's getting
harder to focus your vision and harder
still to quiet the terrified voices in
your mind but you can't get up not
without knowing what is doing this to
you the containment class for SCP 3280
is now Declassified ifed uid and once
more the special containment procedures
have altered too they now explain that
every week a new member of d-class
personnel is to be deposited into the
entity's layer in suevel 2 through
Subterranean access point gamma the
d-class or more accurately the
sacrifices are to be told lies about why
exactly they need to descend to the
lowest point in the facility they're
even given a working flashlight and a
defensive night stick to create the
illusion that the foundation expects
them to ever return from the depths
little do they know they also have a
tiny transmitter sewn into their
jumpsuit this broadcasts a frequency
that will attract an eager SCP 3280 to
the DCL class's location like a
dinnerbell only it can hear the file
specifies that SCP 3280 always prefers
live prey well at least that explains
the dead d-class in sublevel 2 you think
hoping that it will somehow overwhelm
the Disney you're feeling or the nagging
pain in your gut you read on somehow the
file's tone becomes even more severe it
says that failure to maintain the
containment of SCP 3280 will not only
trigger a lockdown it will always call
in the intervention of two different
mobile task forces MTF Iota 12 the
silencers and to 4 also known as water
water everywhere if 12 hours pass from
the point of initial Containment Breach
and the 05 Council hasn't been given the
all clear signal by one of these teams
preparation Begins for an imminent XK
Class end of the world scenario just
reading the words sends you into a cold
sweat end of the world what on Earth is
this creature finally you reach the
description you get to find out what
this horrifying entity actually is but
the last thing you expect is the first
sentence in the file to read SCP 3280 is
a Sapient entity composed of a fluid
physically identical to water capable of
traveling roughly 2 and 1 12 kilm per
hour it's water it's literally a living
thinking blob of water as you read on
the concerning details pile up any water
that the anomalous SCP 3280 water
touches it integrates it into its own
Mass but anytime water is separated from
this Mass it remains anomalous and
continues to act independently when the
creature was first discovered it was a
mere 66.4 l in volume now it's around
2500 the water infected by SCP 3280 is
hostile to all humans and not just in a
defensive manner SCP 3280 will actively
seek out human prey and when it finds
them it forces its mass into any
available body orifice including the
victim's pores this can happen in such a
subtle manner that you may not even
notice yourself being infiltrated but
below this the file has a list of
symptoms for those experiencing 30280
infiltration loss of motor control
weakening of the murcian reflex visual
hallucinations and abdominal pain as you
read the words your stomach gives
another painful churn almost like
something is moving around inside of you
it's all coming together you read on the
file states that SCP 3280 is so
difficult to contain because it exhibits
claustrophobic Tendencies anytime it's
placed inside a container whether
organic or inorganic it escapes with
pressurized water jets that travel at
over 255 mph if the water is inside a
human it may literally explode out of
them killing them in the process your
jittering eyes turned to the gutted body
of security officer Nicholls it all
makes sense now everything is becoming
clear as the pain in your stomach builds
in its intensity the file goes on to say
that if SCP 3280 escapes suev 2
it may be impossible to contain again if
3280 ever escaped the site proper it
would indeed cause an XK Class end of
the world scenario to unfold as 3280
merged with our water cycle and
destroyed all of Humanity on a global
scale it would become truly impossible
for anyone to escape you can't read
anymore the pain in your stomach is
unbearable you jerk from your seat and
stumble out into the Hall doubled over
in agony you can feel it P puling in
there fighting its way out it must have
gotten in through the filthy mop water
you were drinking you didn't even know
it but your fate has been sealed for
hours you've been a dead man walking the
hum of pain builds in your ears and
renders you almost death all you can
hear is the pattern of rain and distant
Thunder you collapse against the glass
feeling the coolness of it against the
skin of your face and in that moment you
see the water droplets on the window
pane reverse dire ction they're
slithering up the glass towards your
face in defiance of gravity then you
realize it's all over and not just for
you SCP 3280 has escaped it's out there
and it's going to drown the entire world
as you collapse to your knees and
prepare to be torn apart from the inside
your final thought is that at least you
won't be alive to see it now check out
SCP 682 ways the foundation tried to
kill the hard toest reptile and SCP 1730
what happened to site 13 for more SCP
Foundation stories that'll have you
sleeping with the lights on